HECHT: Good morning.
For the two or three of you
out there who don't know me,
I'm Bill Hecht,
class of '61, and I'm
your senior employee as head
of the Alumni Association.
[APPLAUSE]
You might wonder how a
guy from the class of '61
got a red coat.
A number of years
ago the class of '24,
which is celebrating
its 70th this year,
had some issues that
needed settling.
And somehow or other I was able
to settle them for that class.
And as a great
privilege and tribute,
they made me an honorary
member of that class,
insisting that I always
wear a freshman tie.
So I now have my own two
connections, a six and a one.
My graduate degree was in '76,
and my undergraduate in '61.
And a 24, which I'm
just as proud of.
And I'm busting
my buttons to say
that in '95, my daughter will
get a master's from this place,
so I'll have another
MIT connection.
I wonder if you all know that
last night's Pops was not only
a very special night for
us, but it was actually
a test for the potential
new conductor of the Pops.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
It is said that he practiced
Arthur Fiedler's hand motions
studiously before the mirror.
And I think that
I'm going to take
on the job of being his
agent and represent him
because I think we can get
a hell of a good contract.
Finally, it's my great
pleasure, in addition
to welcoming you all here
today, to introduce Chuck Vest.
Chuck is president
of MIT, as you know.
He came to us about
four years ago,
and he may be a
little wistful today.
As you know, many people who
come in the fall of four years
graduated about a week ago.
His class, the class
of '94, did leave.
Chuck, I guess fortunately
for us, but perhaps not so
fortunately for him,
still remains with us.
So let me introduce Chuck
Vest, president of MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Thank you very much, Bill.
I'm just signed up for the new
five-year master of engineering
program, that's all.
I've been for years
wanting to get up the nerve
to ask Bill exactly what
this great favor he did
for that class is, but, because
I'm not sure of its legality,
I've been afraid to ask.
On a more serious note
and a very happy one,
I understand that we
have a record number
of alums and families here for
reunions on Technology Day.
You are over 3,000 strong.
My congratulations.
And we all have an
exciting day ahead of us.
[APPLAUSE]
The speakers for today's
program are truly
a stellar group of
men and women who
will talk about art and
culture and the academy
and specifically at MIT.
Here at MIT, where the arts
have evolved over 100 years.
From a single extracurricular
activity in 1884,
the MIT Banjo Club, to a
panoply of artistic and cultural
endeavors that you're going to
have a chance to sample here
today in 1994.
Special thanks go to
Jorge Rodriguez, chairman
of the Technology Day Committee,
and to all the members
the Council for the Arts,
for putting together such
an astounding and exciting
program.
I might add that the watercolor
reproduced in the Technology
Day poster was painted by
one of our graduate students
in the School of Architecture
and Planning, Lian Quan Zhen,
and there are other
examples of his work
on display today in the lobby.
Now to some it might seem odd
that in this bastion of science
and engineering we bring
together our alumni
and alumnae to
celebrate the arts.
But most of you probably had
at least a brush with the arts
at MIT, and many
of you, I'm sure,
became more deeply involved
in our music and theater arts
programs.
And now more than ever, our
students and our faculty
are engaged in a wide range of
artistic and cultural pursuits,
in visual arts, in
architecture, music, theater,
creative writing,
and photography,
as well as in the emerging
media of interactive video,
holography, and
hyperinstruments.
Still, some of
you might ask why.
Well, it is true that
MIT is best known
throughout the world for
the caliber of the engineers
and scientists we send
out from this place.
The Institute has in fact
produced a steady flow
of artists, architects,
musicians, dancers, actors,
and others who are best known
for their artistic endeavors.
We have string players and
wind players, composers
and conductors in orchestras
around the country.
We have actors on
Broadway and in Hollywood.
And we have MIT graduates on
the faculties of music schools
in many other universities.
Of course, most MIT
students continue
to pursue traditional careers
in engineering and science.
But we are no less serious
about teaching music, theater,
and the arts to these students.
The arts, when taught
seriously and deeply,
offer our students opportunities
to expand their imagination,
broaden their
perspective, and imagine
ever-widening new possibilities.
This is true for all of us.
When we develop our ability
to think creatively,
we are able to
find new solutions
to the problems on
which we are working,
both in our laboratories and
in other aspects of our lives.
Take, for example, the
fields of engineering
and particularly
engineering education.
We are moving very dramatically
toward a more integrative style
of education, with
increased emphasis on design
and synthesis and a little
bit less emphasis on analysis
and reductionist science.
I think that art
and an appreciation
for the aesthetic components
of all that people do
is very helpful in this regard.
As we work to improve
the quality of designs
and products, it is
going to be increasingly
important for engineers
to cooperate with artists
to tackle the visual, tactile,
and aesthetic qualities
of their work.
But quite aside from their role
in scientific and engineering
endeavors, the arts
should, of course,
still be an important part of
our lives and of our education.
Why?
Because they are
part of our humanity.
They reflect our
human experience.
The arts give us
a different kind
of connection with
the world, and they
can help us to understand the
many cultures that make up
our community and our world.
The arts allow people from
very different perspectives
and backgrounds to
communicate and to interact
with an almost built-in
degree of mutual respect.
This is important
for our graduates
as they take their skills into
an increasingly interdependent,
global, and multicultural world.
And this is very
important for MIT.
The more innovative we are in
celebrating and encouraging
the richness and diversity
of our community,
the better off
all of us will be.
In sum, the arts at MIT
are essential elements
of our education and
of our community life.
Not only are they healthy
here, they are thriving.
This is great testimony to
the talent, the dedication,
and the enthusiasm of a great
many faculty and students.
And it is particular
testimony to one person
who has done an extraordinary
job in stimulating
and supporting the arts
since she arrived here
at MIT in 1989.
I refer, of course, to my
colleague Professor Ellen
Harris, associate provost
for the arts at MIT.
Ellen is a distinguished
scholar of music
who is also known widely
as a soprano soloist.
She came to us from the
University of Chicago,
where she was a professor
of music and head
of the Department of Music.
As a scholar, she has been
recognized for her work
on the music of Handel.
As a singer, she is best
known for her dramatic stage
performances.
Those of you who were here
for commencement last week
and heard her sing
the national anthem
know precisely what I mean.
Ellen's arrival on campus
was the final fulfillment
of a set of recommendations
made in 1987 by an arts review
committee, which recommended the
appointment of a senior officer
who would also be a faculty
member in either the performing
or visual arts, someone to
take broad responsibility
as an advocate,
leader, and coordinator
for the creative arts
program here at MIT.
Believe me, Ellen Harris
serves superbly in that role.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Professor Ellen Harris.
[APPLAUSE]
HARRIS: Thank you, Chuck.
Good morning.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
HARRIS: Oh, good.
It's often been said that
at MIT, one's education
is like taking a drink
from a fire hose.
What I have noticed is
that so is Tech Day.
We have here before
9:00 in the morning
after having you out
very late last night,
and I appreciate seeing
you all here so bright
and raring to go.
I'm proud and privileged
to welcome you
to The Wonder of It All,
The Arts at MIT, Technology
Day 1994.
And I want to add my thanks
to Jorge Rodriguez, the chair
of the alumni Tech Day Committee
and also to Eliza [? Dame, ?]
who does so much, more than
I could possibly say, to make
Tech Day work year after year.
Many people like to talk
about the arts at MIT
as if it's an anomaly,
as if it's a surprise,
or as if it's something new.
But of course, you know
better than anyone else
that that is not the case.
The arts have been a part
of MIT since its founding.
MIT was the first school
to establish a School
of Architecture in 1868.
It actually began offering
courses in architecture
in its first year, 1865.
In that same year, we
were offering courses
in photography and in drawing.
In 1884 we not only
established the Banjo Club,
but we established
the Glee Club.
In 1928 we established
Drama Shop,
the forerunner of our
theater curriculum today.
And in 1948, John
Corley came to MIT
to establish the MIT Band, an
organization that he continues
to conduct today.
[APPLAUSE]
In 1950, the Hayden
Gallery opened,
which was the forerunner of our
now internationally renowned
List Visual Arts Center.
But perhaps most importantly,
in 1944, 50 years ago today,
MIT first established its
eight-semester sequence
in humanities.
Those of you who have been
at the Institute since 1944
will remember your eight
courses in the humanities.
They used to be different
than they are today.
But in 1944 they
included, I think,
a first-year course in writing
and English literature,
second-year course in history,
third-year course where
you could choose from
a number of subjects,
including economics.
And in the fourth year, a
wider selection of courses,
including a yearlong
course in music.
Because of this
eight-semester sequence
of courses, which parallels
the eight semester
courses in science, MIT
has had for many years
a program in education
which has been referred
to here as dual literacy.
MIT students have been
asked to be literate
not only in science but in
humanities and in the arts.
In fact, MIT may be one of the
few educational institutions
in the country that asks
this of its students.
It is very, very easy
at many liberal arts
institutions to
avoid the sciences.
Not so easy at MIT to
avoid the humanities.
In fact, this dual
literacy has meant
that we have within
our students and alums
many people who have gone
on to careers in the arts.
In fact, in the class of 1994,
I can think of four cases
immediately.
Two young men who
have double majored
in mathematics and
music, both of whom
are going on right now
to graduate school, one
to the University of Chicago
and one to Duke in music
composition.
We have another
student who majored
in civil engineering
who has received
a full scholarship to pursue
writing at Boston University.
And we have another student
who majored in theater
at MIT who is going on to pursue
his work in theater who hopes
to establish his own theater
company in the countryside
of Mexico.
I sometimes think
we must graduate
the most scientifically
literate artists in the world.
But this is not
something that was
just true of the class of 1994.
And I was looking at
the reunion classes
for some other examples.
And obviously, we have
a lot of people today
here from the class of 1944.
Right?
[APPLAUSE]
Well, one of your members,
John [? Bevicki, ?]
who graduated with a
major in management,
has gone on to be a
very well-known composer
and conductor who has
been for many years
on the faculty of the
Berkeley School of Music.
From the class of '64.
'64?
Do I hear the class of '64?
We have John Miller, who
double majored in humanities
and engineering who has made his
career as principal bassoonist
with the Minnesota Orchestra.
Class of '69.
[APPLAUSE]
You had with you for
some time James Woods,
who was majoring in
political science
before he went on to become
a very well-known actor.
In '79--
[SPARSE APPLAUSE]
I think we need
more energy, folks.
Liz Maruska, who went on
to become a practicing
artist on the West
Coast who paints
beautiful canvases in
watercolor and gouache,
expressing time and space.
And finally, class
of '89, five years.
[APPLAUSE]
Ken Goodson, who majored in
both mechanical engineering
and music, received
his master of science
in '91 in mechanical
engineering, his PhD in '93,
is now studying and
performing as a baritone
soloist in Germany.
I love about Ken that when
he performed at Tanglewood
as an MIT grad, it
is only appropriate
that, when singing in
Stravinsky's work "The Flood,"
Ken Goodson played
the role of God.
But obviously, MIT does not
graduate all of its students
to go on in the arts.
You don't need to be
an arts professional
to benefit from the arts.
And whether you worked in Doc
Edgerton's strobe photography
lab, or perhaps
became interested
in physics through
Berenice Abbot's
extraordinary photographs
of physical phenomena that
were published in many
high school textbooks
and that were taken
at MIT, or whether you
played in the symphony,
or sang in the Glee Club,
or acted in a
theatrical production,
I'm sure that at some point
art touched your life at MIT
and has continued to touch
your life thereafter.
Arts offer us discipline.
Anyone who has practiced
the piano knows that.
Arts offer us imagination.
They offer us the
flexibility of a pursuit
where there is not
one right answer.
But they also offer us
new ways of organization,
of organization of sound
and space and time.
The arts offer us a doorway
into cultures other than our own
that enable us not only
to tolerate but respect
difference.
The arts challenge us, surprise
us, sometimes they anger us.
But the arts also bring
us wonder and joy.
And today we hope to explore
through our presentations
the wonder and joy of
the arts today at MIT.
This, of course,
leads me directly
to our first speaker, Philip
Morrison, Institute professor
emeritus at MIT.
You are probably familiar
with his work in astrophysics
and cosmology, maybe less
familiar with his work
as a filmmaker.
I first came to know
Philip through a copy
of a keynote
address that he gave
in 1986 for the 15th anniversary
of the Council for the Arts
at MIT, an organization
founded in 1971
to advise and support MIT in the
expansion of its arts programs.
At that time he
said, and I quote,
"It's clear that if an
institution like this one which
deals with the material world
did not have the side of art,
it would be a self-defeating
proposition which in the end
would be all genetic seed
and no fruit to the apple.
And an apple is
not made that way."
I think that I can do no
better in introducing Professor
Morrison than to quote his
colleague Victor Weisskopf, who
said of him, "Scientific
knowledge and understanding is
not a purely cerebral affair.
It is soaked with
emotion, excitement,
and nervous tension,
as everybody
knows who has ever heard
Professor Morrison speak."
Ladies and gentlemen,
please help me
to welcome Professor Morrison.
[APPLAUSE]
MORRISON: Thank you very much.
I'm going to talk to
them about it, I think.
I have much equipment here,
all of which seems to work.
Especially impressed by the
video projection system.
The Wonder of It All
at MIT, Arts at MIT
is a very nice title.
Doesn't say much.
Commits very few speakers.
I would certainly like to
affix firmly onto the word
"wonder" because clearly
that's the kind of motive which
lies behind nearly all the
things that go on at MIT.
Translated, as eventually
they are, into the hard tasks
of earning a living and
making this world work.
The old classical
Chinese scholars
always like to pretend that the
ideas they had were very old.
So they found some
mysterious figure
of the past who nobody
knew much about, typically
the Yellow Emperor.
And they said, well, the Yellow
Emperor first said, and then
they made up their own books.
We don't do that now.
We have a much more
forward looking.
And we don't look
back in general.
It's always new.
That's the same
error in reverse.
People have this tendency
for bipolar positioning,
bipolar stability of large
axes because everything
is both-- has something
old and something new
or it's not been
pursued very far.
That's the typical lesson.
Ask a historian, he'll
take it back for you.
Ask a projector of the
future, he'll push it forward.
Both things lie in time.
I wanted, however, and I
didn't always know this.
And I became more and
more convinced of it
in the past recent
times, a few years,
maybe, the proposition that
this issue that we now debate
is extraordinarily old.
I could invoke no
newer a phrase for it
than this Latin tag of the
Institute, mens et manus, mind
and hand, to talk about it.
Because, of course, that is the
exquisite pleasure of the MIT
ambiance that minds and hands
are equally well occupied.
That means to say that a
lot of mechanical things
are done, a lot of things
in the material world
or with the refractory symbols
of the world that are hammered
away at, whether it be metal
or melodies or whatever it is,
but that's not done
by and large by rote.
Obviously some rote goes
into all operations, experts
become routinized, but
thought is at the basis.
And it turns out that
that unity, which
is a profound unity between
art and the triune quality
of modifying and knowing the
world physically-- craft,
engineering and science
in their relationships--
goes back a very long time.
And I brought along a few
slides to justify that
and to get us well started.
So it's not a new task
that we're looking into.
This wonderful picture in the
center, collection of rocks,
deserves some close attention.
Those rocks are
not natural rocks.
The fact that they are
quite similar, I think,
is pretty evident.
It's also quite evident
if you look more closely,
not easy to see, perhaps.
It's better to handle them.
We can't do that.
But I think it's
enough to suggest it
in a context like this.
You can see the three edges
here, the double ones there.
Every one has faceted edges.
This one has, in fact, a slight
double kind of blade-like edge
and so on.
This is a pile of rocks,
a section, a collection,
made by the excavators
in Olduvai Gorge
in the rift of East Africa.
These were not found that way.
They were found stratum after
stratum carefully located,
carefully arranged in position
so they could be dated.
But the photographer had
simply gathered a lot of them
to give us an impression
of how many hundreds,
indeed many thousands, of
these stone tools are found.
Now the remarkable
part about them.
This, of course,
is mens et manus.
Mens is pretty thin still.
These are not even
our own species.
These are our distant forebears.
They were poor.
They first walked the Earth
fearful of the beasts.
Pretty soon that
stopped, and the beasts
tended to avoid them.
Before that, perhaps
even they scavenged
on the kill of the lion.
But sooner or later, this kind
of operation symbolized here,
mind and hand, began to
change where they were.
And they did marvelous things
on a very slow time scale.
The pieces represented
in this collection,
just that arbitrary piece
of a large collection,
are measured not by centuries
but by thousands of centuries.
Yes, by hundreds of
thousands of years.
A few hundred thousand
years corresponds
to a typical
collection at Olduvai,
which might extend a
million years or more.
But to be generous, we'll
say a few thousand centuries.
Now the striking part of
this is that these tools,
without very much
change, are found
over a very large
part of the world,
as the next slide will show.
There it is.
Here are famous sites.
Anyone who has read anything
about early archaeology
will recognize these
kinds of locations.
From Britain up here into
Europe, France at the Pyrenees,
especially very
important in there,
all across Africa, East Africa.
Here we have Olduvai itself.
And down to Cape Town.
So from Britain to Cape Town
and from Cape Town across Asia,
Central Asia, India, North
China, Peking, further
north still, and into Java.
All these, the major
sites, each site
feathers out into many,
many little excavations.
And from all of these places
about the same kind of tools
are collected.
Yes, the experts argue a
bit, and they can somewhat
classify them.
But it's really quite
hard to date them
except by the attendant
pieces of mineral,
which can help you to date
them by radioactive means.
But you'll notice that
not one site is found
in these islands or Australia.
And I've left out the Americas.
No use to put it on
the map because not one
site of this kind has ever
surely been found in America.
No, Australia, the great
islands near Australia,
and the two Americas
do not belong
to these people, who
I don't wish to say
are-- they are our ancestors.
Cannot speak ill of them.
They were, in fact,
the Prometheans.
Because somewhere in the
middle of their span,
Homo erectus figured out how
to make and control fire.
And the hammer at
MIT is entirely
secondary to the
fire and all that
goes with that symbolically.
So I don't show you those
sites, though, of course,
there are very many
sites in America.
But none of them show
the bones or the tools
of these ancient folk.
We truly, like the Australians,
Australian Aboriginals,
the Native Americans,
are the modern humans,
like all the rest of
this place has also been
filled in by modern humans.
I don't mean to say that
we're, of course, we're not--
most modern humans live
in this part of the world.
But the same species
occupies this whole region.
And only after a long time,
after thousands of centuries,
it managed, they managed, in the
course of some internal change,
which is what we would
call a change in species
to Homo sapiens,
they managed by means
that are not-- can
be well debated,
interesting to
study-- they managed
to be able to cross the then
much shallower coastal seas.
And finally the great
gulf of the Timor
Trench and come somehow by
canoe or raft to Australia.
And in the same way go
across the relenting Arctic,
where the glaciers were melting,
and follow the coastline
of America.
And go down the full length of
both continents rather quickly.
And that completed the
occupation of the world
by modern humans.
So we are the new world,
not because of Columbus
or any feature of
historical importance.
Those are small matters.
The real thing was, we were
new because the new people, who
filled up the old
lands very well,
had a way also to get to new
lands never before occupied.
So our histories go back only
a few hundred centuries, not
a few thousand centuries.
There's an order of
magnitude difference
between the kind of thing you
saw in the Olduvai rocks--
bifaces, choppers, hand
axes, they're called--
and the kind of thing that
came when a new set of persons
of whom we are all descended.
We can prove by the
deepest of biological means
how united the whole world
is in our single species,
with subspecies,
as we well know.
And the next slide
will show what
you find in these new sites.
Now please compare these,
which are nice American pieces.
They were made about
10,000 or 12,000,
well, 12,000 or
14,000 years ago.
These are found in
a region in Montana.
And of course, they're
specialized for killing
big game.
And if you'd like to know what
the big game was-- probably
you do know-- it was elephants.
Pieces quite like this,
spear points like this,
have been found in contact with
the bones of bison and mammoth.
And of course, where the
other rocks had 10 or 20
rather cunning blows struck,
which you and I could not do,
which people can train
themselves to do today,
these have many hundreds
of knowing strokes
to chip the blade
just correctly.
And even along the
edge you can see
to sharpen it with a wonderful
thing, very detailed marks
up there, all of which are
significant in producing
a handy and useful blade.
So I have no doubt to say this
is craftsmanship, possibly even
engineering.
At least it's
high-quality craftsmanship
because we know now that
many of these blades
have to be heat treated
in order to allow
the chert and the flint to
respond to the chipping.
But now I'd like to go a little
farther and show what they did.
And it happens that the
preservations I have now
are again the same new
people, our people,
but now coming
from France and not
from Montana, the following.
A bone object used
for working sinew
and straightening arrow shafts.
You can see the hole there.
But it wasn't enough
to make it utilitarian.
It has this marvelous
leaping horse
worked into the same material.
And this is about
200 or 250 centuries
old from Bruniquel
Cave in France.
We have art so much
from France and Spain
because the caverns are
so well protected there.
They guarded the art
behind stalactites
for many thousands of years.
And the next slide perhaps
even more striking.
An image itself, an
elk of the period.
The biologists will find
fossils that fit it quite well.
Beautifully drawn in
charcoal and ocher
on the wall of the
French cave, this
on the famous cave of Lascaux.
So I rest the case
that the relationship,
the change, that
came to human beings,
we don't exactly
know what it is.
Most likely it was
the acquisition
of a powerful
language, which enabled
them to work cooperatively
and to model the future,
gave rise to the
craft and the art,
which you unmistakably
see here which
goes back not merely thousands
of years but tens of thousands
of years.
This particular piece is dated
about 15,000 or 18,000 years
ago, the previous one
about 20,000 years ago.
And all from that
same flood of persons
who occupied the world maybe
in all not more than half
a million of them by the time
the Americas were settled.
And we've grown, then, from that
half million to half trillion,
a very large number of
powers of 10 in population.
Thank you.
Now the linkage between the
craft-- engineering, science,
art-- between hand and
mind expressed in this way,
I maintain this is
demonstrably old.
Indeed, we can see it even
in the beginnings of science,
in the time of the Enlightenment
in the late Renaissance.
You couldn't buy
a microscope that
wasn't worked up and chased
and engraved to bear some art.
Partly that was style,
I'm not denying it.
Partly that was royal patronage,
I'm not denying that either.
Nevertheless, the work of
the hand was to be admired.
And it was rare to have
such skilled craftsmanship
in these new materials
with a new purpose.
And to some extent, we've
lost that feeling because
of a high utilitarian quality
and the already great expense
of making the complex
instruments, which
now replace the sledgehammer
of the MIT seal.
Or augment the sledgehammer.
I don't want to run
down the sledgehammer.
Still a very
indispensable instrument.
What I would like to
emphasize, though,
is that this connection
is a profound connection.
And I'd like to describe a
little bit why I think it's so
and why it parts the
hand/mind relationship
from a more symbolic one, which
is not absent from either.
Any of you who have tried
to learn a craft or a skill
or, above all, an art knows
how very close the reaction
of a hand and the mind
must be to make anything
work the way you choose.
And if you don't do that,
another draft is to be made.
Now of course, those
who deal in symbols
alone have some of
the same quality,
but the hand is
much less present.
The symbols are, by
nature, more conventional.
What is characteristic of art
and science and engineering
together is they represent--
almost always they're
presented to us, and
they need to be presented
to us, in concrete form.
In single concrete examples.
Perhaps something more
than the poet Blake
called "minute
particulars," which
he felt all art and
science were compacted.
But certainly not generalities.
Generalities edge towards
philosophical description.
True, there's a big
domain in between.
There are theorems
and propositions
that are indispensable
that come out of thought
and which govern many
of the things we do.
But I think it's fair
to say that works of art
and the data of science
and works of the engineer
are all concrete examples.
And if you don't have those, you
have a very dry subject indeed
that consists of nothing
of theorems about mechanics
without motions or diagrams
or examples or particulars,
which I suffered through
as a graduate student
once long ago at
another university
when I was studying mechanics.
We couldn't ask
questions, and we also
couldn't understand
the propositions.
We sure could learn
the words quite well.
Now there are
differences, of course.
I think of the
principal characteristic
of art, which I admit is
somewhat rapidly losing
that hasn't [? lost ?] yet.
It can be seen in
almost all parts of it.
Its products, its
particulars are
perceptual to the human being.
It's very hard to imagine art
translated through-- it's not
impossible, we see
it today-- translated
through some intermediate
device, which turns it
into printouts and numbers.
Then you have to regraph it.
This is hardly art.
The immediacy is gone,
though, of course,
a great deal of the
world of science,
great deal of the
data of science
go beyond human perception,
involve intermediation
by instrumentation
of complicated kinds
and auxiliary calculations
to bring together
the reading of the instruments
or program inside the computer,
which is doing the same thing.
And by and large, that's
the biggest distinction
I can see on the side
of how the work is done.
It is also true that
they are united in this.
Niels Bohr defined
science not only as effort
to order the world, which surely
it is, but there it does not
deal-- it does not differ from
philosophy or, for that matter,
from poetry.
But it seeks to bring in
new experience, which again
is close to art, though
perhaps rather different
from the philosophers' work.
And if we talk
about engineering,
I think we have to say to bring
new means for the game you've
experienced.
This too is necessary.
But all of this
definitional style
would very much connect these
two or three-- it's hard for me
to think of them as
three-- but certainly
multiple view of these matters.
I'd like to go still further
and talk about their internal--
the way it appears to
practitioners a bit.
All of you, as students,
were practitioners.
All of you now are practitioners
in some direction or another.
And I think you'll
recognize, feel sympathy
with what I say when
I say that there
are a couple of
apparently poor divisions,
contradictions, opposites,
which have to be
united in each of these things.
A curious but quite realistic
account of what people do.
For example, the passive
absorption of information
to learn a language, to learn
mathematical formulation,
to learn the use of
a pen or a brush,
to learn the language of the
stage, whatever it might be.
To learn the notes of
the scale and the keys.
All of those things
are done, can
be done as a passive
game where someone
feeds the information, a book, a
program, a person, and you gain
it.
But of the other side, activity
is indispensable, especially
if you learn those things
with that beautiful word
productivity.
So it can again recombine
them for yourselves.
We know people who teach physics
at MIT and everywhere else
that the solving of problems,
onerous as it may be,
is a way to secure the active
knowledge of the things
passively observed,
underlined in
yellow marker, the big
propositions in the textbook.
You've got to put them together.
You've got to make
them work for you.
You have to feel somewhat
what we say at home with them.
Until that's happened,
no genuine understanding
will come in.
The answering of multiple choice
tests in familiar language,
choosing the right
one of six, is not
a very powerful
test for science,
for engineering, or for art.
It may be good
enough for learning
certain received
bodies of truth, fine.
I'm not against it entirely.
But it is clearly in our day,
it's a basis of controversy
and surely overused.
So we have to combine the
passive and the active,
and activity is the sine qua
non of the hand and the mind.
The same similar dichotomy
goes between the analytic
and the synthetic.
It was said in popular
psychology only a few years
ago-- it was quite
popular in the magazines--
there were halves of the
brain, the left and the right.
And one attended to
the holistic things,
the organization, the concepts.
And one attended to the details,
the rigorous, logical thinking.
One was suitable for
children, one for grownups,
and that was the general idea.
People who said that, of
course, were mostly writers.
They understood
writing very well.
They knew how hard it was
to formulate good sentences
and paragraphs.
And they said, well,
in the kindergarten
they can draw quite
well and make images,
and that's enough for that.
Of course, this is a caricature.
It's a very bad proposition.
Analytics and synthetic
again are together.
The analyst indeed
may take things apart.
But the tools he uses were
themselves synthesized
by earlier designers
who synthesized
the scalpel or the method
of least squares, whatever
it might be, by putting
together something new that
had not existed before.
So I reject that as a
harsh division of the world
and say no, both halves
of the mind are necessary.
All parts of the
mind, like both hands.
And the unitarity of this
is visible in the sense
that we all know that for
every geometrical statement
in Euclid, an algebraic
equivalent can
be formed and vice versa.
The symbols of language, the
symbols of x and y and plus,
are no more foreign than
the lines and the angles.
They're just different
ways of presentation,
and they have a
one-to-one correspondence.
Of course, the
symbolism of our world
is so powerful
now it extends, it
goes beyond what
we can easily draw.
You can do n dimensionality.
I accept that and use it daily.
But this is the issue.
Now there is a feeling that
there's a difference in tone.
And there is some difference.
The scientists and the
engineers seem serious.
They're concerned with matters
of prosperity and penury
or sometimes life and death
or sometimes peace and war.
And this seems more
serious, perhaps,
than the more playful
activity of the artist.
But I recommend you, thinking
through our own language,
the word "play" has
wide connotations.
The player may play
Medea or Hamlet, hardly
a lighthearted affair,
something plumbing
the depths of human behavior.
Lightness of heart is
not the whole story.
The primary colors and
the cube, the sphere,
are fine things for
the elementary school,
indispensable for
the small child.
But they are not the
whole story of play.
Play, which is unique
in the vertebrates
and best developed in those
closest to us, is profound.
I worked a lot
with Charles Ames,
who said that one of the most
serious activities in life
was play, and he demonstrated
it every day by what he did.
Play is a means of-- clearly
what the word implies--
model making of the future.
What would it be
to do like that?
Not to carry it out?
Not to make that
full investment?
But to acquire the mastery in a
more benign, a more acceptable,
a more easily
entered environment.
And that is what play is.
And since you cannot master
the world in a stroke,
play is an indispensable
feature of human behavior.
From word play of the
infant and the mother
in the home to the most
profound thought of an Einstein
or a composer of great value,
Bach in the course of his work,
as any exposure to
art demonstrates,
these things have and the
scientists too must have it.
I'd like to say a word for
playful engineering, which
I think is an important
issue of our time
that we have not
yet fully engaged.
It's not new.
There always has
been such a thing.
I'd like to show an
example of it in a slide.
I hope you can
recognize this slide.
It's a very unusual slide.
It was made in 1936.
It shows the greatest--
one of the greatest--
works of playful engineering,
the Eiffel Tower.
You can perhaps recognize the
Avenue [INAUDIBLE] down here
and the arches of
the Eiffel Tower
there, all heavily illuminated
in this time exposure from 1936
where, of course,
what you see is
a pyrotechnic display,
fireworks, off all
parts of the Eiffel Tower.
But of course, the Eiffel
Tower was built strictly
as a playful operation,
a decoration for Paris
for the 1889 World's Fair there
by a great structural engineer.
It worked 10,000 tons of
wrought iron, not of steel,
of wrought iron and rivets.
And made playfully.
Of course, managing to extract
a fee from the people who
come so it can keep going,
keep itself painted,
and, indeed, pay the
shareholders quite
a considerable income, I
understand, over the years.
But nevertheless,
that's its foundation.
It doesn't do anything but
stand there magnificently.
At first, of course, attacked
by half the artists and writers
in Paris and now inseparable
from the nature of the city.
And I'm sure that you could
not possibly tear it down
without a major
revolution swirling
about the base of the tower.
Now playful engineering is not
enough practiced in our time.
It is practiced some.
We all know about it.
We know about it in sports,
where it's become a specialty
and almost lost
its playful quality
because of its heavy rewards.
And at MIT, from the impromptu
and very lighthearted hack,
of which I need not
give you any examples,
through the pedal-driven
aircraft of great renown.
To the wonderful stroboscopic
work of Papa Flash,
the late Doc Edgerton.
To the sophisticated work,
whose 25th anniversary
is being celebrated tomorrow at
the Center of Advanced Visual
Studies, which I remember
for sort of three
or four works of grand
works, not single
works, but whole campaigns of
playful engineering, mechanisms
of extraordinary
wit and pleasure.
The use of aerial
photography as an art form,
not as a geodetic study or
a way of measuring crops.
And sky art, lasers and balloons
on grand scale just beginning
in this world in
the last few years.
And I'm quite sure also
that the Palais du Louvre
has been recently subjected to
something which is architecture
and playful in its qualities
and at the same time profoundly
purposeful.
And I'm sure that IM Pei and
Dean Mitchell will describe
something about that in
their talk of recent work
just to come.
Now I'm going to
close, and I want
to close with a somewhat novel
end, which I had not really
planned but it was
forced out of me as I
went through these thoughts
in the last few weeks.
I see one danger.
The danger is an
extraordinarily clear one,
and I think we have found
the best way to avoid it.
I'll tell you what that is
and see if you agree with me.
Please think about it.
It's something novel.
It's something of great
importance to all of us.
And it needs
widespread attention.
And that is, it's
clear that nowadays art
produces its own truths.
The artwork is not judged by its
comparison with another canon,
necessarily.
Yes, it might be of the School
of Beaux-Art, it might not.
The schools are various.
The techniques are innumerable.
The subject matter,
the minute particulars,
are as wide as can be.
And I think we should
accept that as the freedom
that the artist has.
Of course, he may
follow a strict form.
He may wish to do that.
Or he may break loose
into something quite new.
But in any case, there's
no other criteria,
no external one,
the scientist must--
the input is what counts.
The data must be
reliably presented.
The engineer, the
object must work
for the purpose of
which it was intended
or some purpose close to that.
But the artist, it is
the output that counts.
Does it work for the
purpose he intended it,
to amuse, to entertain, to
teach, whatever it might be?
It doesn't matter
how he got there.
He isn't responsible to show
you the data on which he worked.
And on the other hand, this
leads to a great danger,
of which a very tiny example.
My wife, Phyllis Morrison,
has helped me produce
for the next, last slide.
Well, it's the Eiffel
Tower again, right?
In fact, it's the
same-- you see it's
the same pyrotechnic picture.
But spontaneously, with the
matter of a few seconds,
Phyllis has managed to
give the kind of impression
that there's a colorful
pyrotechnic display coming
from the great tower.
And of course, you are
all well sophisticated
enough for the
images and with now
markers to recognize
that of course that's
nothing to do with the
Eiffel Tower at all.
What does it have to do with?
It has to do with a
35-millimeter slide that
represented the Eiffel Tower
in 1936, which she has then
modified with just a very
small, spontaneous artistic work
to make the point here.
The image, however, is
itself, it is there,
and it means something that
is actually quite striking.
And now the trouble is, we
make images so well today.
We make so many.
We can make them so seamlessly.
We can change their appearance
in every way, not only
visual images but even, speaking
more metaphorically, auditory
and the rest, that there is
a cut-off between the world
represented, may
not be represented,
but even those things
when they are represented,
well represented of the
image, are no longer
good maps of each other.
The artist's intervention
is so powerful
that he has ended that.
Now that is not new to us.
We all experience it
internally, and it
is probably indispensable to
the human mind and the way
we have evolved.
It is what we call
the world of dream.
In dream, visual
images are produced,
which have maybe some
semblance of your experience,
sometimes not perhaps.
But when they have
semblance, we know very well
that those dreams are not the
relatively close approximations
to what is going on, that the
eyes, which are always limited,
and the video screen, which is
equally and similarly limited,
bring to you approximations
of the real world.
Now what I am trying
to say is a danger
that, if we have, as we do
have, the growth of the greatest
20th century arts, the one
that attracts most people,
and I think has gradually,
gradually increased
its salience is the cinema.
And I strongly suspect
the 21st century
will make the video equivalent
of the cinema, with its music,
with its changes, with
its probable 3D nature,
and its motions and change,
will probably transcend
all previous visual experiences,
will make an enormous push
upon the world.
Whereas the capital
of this world
is only going to double
or triple and plateau out.
There isn't room for more.
There's not room in
the atmospheric balance
and the heat sources for more.
These sources of information
and image are enormous,
and they will continue.
And the real question is that we
not be swamped in a dream world
where we no longer pay attention
to what the representation was
of but only the nature of
the representation itself.
That is, after all,
the artist's task.
And I cannot think of a better
way of understanding that
problem, of conquering it,
than by having people know both
sides of the operation, who
have studied the arts to see how
much you can do to make
entertaining and wonderful
things that didn't exist,
but also how much you can do
to represent scrupulously
and meticulously the data
of the real world, the actual
performance of engineering
without hyperbole and public
relations and the rest.
To take only one
side, well, stay away
from the other,
that will not work
because people are too clever
and they'll transcend it.
What is the best is to expose
them both, come right up front
and say, yes, this can be done.
The artist has one direction,
the engineer scientist
has another.
Both recognize their
enormous similarity.
But by their mutual
understanding,
we can have a world which both
contains dreams but is not
solely based on it.
And I think that's the only kind
of a world which is safe for us
to try to carry on the legacy
of the canyon at Olduvai.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HARRIS: Can I help in any way?
MORRISON: I think
just by holding there.
HARRIS: Well, I thought I was
being really smart to take back
the relationship
between mens et manus,
mind and hand, to the
establishment of MIT.
But as has happened to me
many times since coming here
five years ago, I was put to
shame by one of my colleagues
who has now taken it back
tens of thousands of years
and has put that relationship
into the perspective
that we must view it.
And has not only taken it back
tens of thousands of years,
but has told us and
warned us of the future
and of the continuing
importance of the relationship.
[APPLAUSE]
May we remember Professor
Morrison's words
and continue to pursue playful
engineering and serious art.
Our next speakers
will in fact talk
about a specific relationship
between mens et manus,
between art and engineering
in the world of architecture.
We are very honored
today to have
with us architect IM
Pei, class of 1940,
formally with the firm of
Pei Cobb Freed & Partners.
Of course, Mr. Pei is very well
known for many, many buildings,
and I will not list them all.
Some of them are particularly
important for the arts,
including, of course,
the Louvre, the East
Wing of the National
Gallery in Washington, DC.
And many MIT alums are familiar
particularly with the Morrison
Hall for the Dallas
Symphony Orchestra,
a remarkable building.
At MIT, Mr. Pei has not only
designed the Wiesner Building
on Ames Street but the arch
to that building, which
is a gateway into East Campus
as you cross Ames Street.
Also, not, I think,
coincidentally,
when you are walking
toward the campus,
frame his three buildings
in the main quadrangle
with, in perspective,
the MIT Dome overall.
The three buildings
on the main campus
with their very stark geometry
of verticals and horizontals,
triangles and rectangles.
Most recently, or
not most recently,
but among Mr. Pei's
most recent works
are the Bank of
China in Hong Kong
and the Four Seasons
Hotel in New York City.
And I think we will be hearing
about some of these works
today.
Mr. Pei has also been
affiliated with MIT since 1972
as a member of the Council
for the Arts at MIT.
And we appreciate his years
of membership on that group.
Talking to Mr. Pei today will
be Dean William Mitchell.
Dean Mitchell has been
at MIT since 1992,
and he is particularly
well known
for his book, published
by the MIT Press,
The Reconfigured Eye, which
deals with digital photography
and in fact visual
images that do not
represent the real world.
Dean Mitchell is
working very hard
in the School of Architecture to
lead the School of Architecture
into the 21st century with
his virtual design studios
and the design studios of
the future using computer
technology to create
a seamless process
from the initial designs
through to the communications
with clients,
engineers, and others.
Please help me to welcome IM
Pei and Dean William Mitchell.
[APPLAUSE]
MITCHELL: Well, it's truly
a wonderful privilege
to have you here and talk
about architecture with IM Pei.
We're going to [INAUDIBLE]
we're going to after a while.
And then if there are
questions from the audience,
we will be delighted to
take them. [INAUDIBLE]
conversation ongoing.
Now when we were talking
about [INAUDIBLE]
So we decided we would be
[INAUDIBLE] that project
was unfolded over
a number of years
before the Louvre in Paris.
Now I think everybody who
knows the arts at all knows
that at the Louvre, IM Pei
created an extraordinarily
[INAUDIBLE]
CREW: Should we just
walk them out or what?
MITCHELL: What made [INAUDIBLE]
so obvious [INAUDIBLE]
extraordinarily large
and complex [INAUDIBLE].
Redoing the Louvre is in fact--
CREW: Excuse me, can I
just place this microphone?
[APPLAUSE]
MITCHELL: Could anybody
hear what I was saying?
AUDIENCE: No.
MITCHELL: Okay.
Redoing the Louvre is--
this sounds much better.
Redoing the Louvre
is an extraordinarily
large and complex project
involving technical problems,
organizational problems,
political problems, certainly.
Problems of very complex
cultural symbolism.
So what we thought
we'd do today is
to ask Mr. Pei to describe
a little bit of his thought
processes, what the problem
is about, the solution that he
finally derived.
And then we'll take some
time to discuss this truly
magnificent project.
So Mr. Pei.
PEI: Professor Morrison talked
about hundreds of centuries.
I'm talking today on the
subject of the Louvre
about eight centuries,
the history of 800 years.
But these are very important 800
years, for the French at least.
[LAUGHTER]
It's the building of the period
during which French nation was
born.
It's a period that I would
say is roughly parallel,
the recent French history.
In fact, it's also a wonderful
symbol, for them at least,
of French civilization.
So therefore, the problem of
the Louvre for the architect
is not just a technical
problem, architectural problem.
But it's a problem that
has many, many challenges.
I would like to start
off by telling you
something about the
history of the Louvre.
Now I don't have too
much time, but I'll
try to make it very brief
and therefore incomplete.
It started in 1202 by I
think you can call him
a French king,
Philippe Auguste, who
built this fortress on the
right side of the Seine
to protect the Ile-de-France,
which is now the Ile de la
Cite, which is the place
where the French, the heart
of French life at that
time in Paris took place.
It was built as a fortress,
la dungeon, as they call it.
And it's important
because I wish
I had taken some slides to
show you what it is like today.
But anyway, it was
a wonderful building
where they put prisoners,
where they put ammunition.
It's a very important
place to protect,
let's say, something
that they considered
to be very important.
It lasted as a dungeon or
as a fortress for roughly,
I would say, maybe 200 years.
It did not become really
a place for the kings
to live in until about the
end of the 14th century.
And I think Charles
V was the king
that one should remember because
that's the beginning of Louvre.
Not only as a place
for the king to live in
but also the beginning
of French art.
The first library
of France was there
and the collection of many,
many objects of Charles V
was displayed there.
Now for how many
years since then?
1400 to today, I would
say, 500 years, 600 years.
Nearly all of the
French kings that you
know of of any importance have
either lived there, died there,
married there, and born there.
So therefore it's
an important place.
So therefore this is
not really surprising
that when someone
like myself-- I
guess I can consider myself an
American of Chinese descent--
asked to tamper with
a very important part
of French history.
So I'm going to go
through this in two phases
to show you what I went through.
Phase one lasted five years,
from 1983 to 19-- six years,
to 1989.
And during those
six years the plan
was laid, how to deal
with the problem as a very
complex problem.
And the pyramid was built. But
before the pyramid was built,
we had a lot of trouble.
We wasted two years.
It's the media that I had
to deal with at that time,
and I was totally unprepared.
And my French language is just
not adequate for that purpose.
But I had to deal
with the media to try
to convince the French that
this was the right thing to do.
So therefore, even though
it took six years, but only
four of those six
years were devoted
to architecture and the
building of the phase one.
Now phase two is less
spectacular in the sense
of public information.
But it's perhaps the
more important of the two
because it completed a
wing called Richelieu.
And without that wing, there
would be no Louvre today.
And we couldn't get
that wing until 1985.
The wing, I'll tell
you what the wing is.
The wing was occupied by
the Ministry of Finance ever
since, oh, I would
say, Napoleon III.
Only 200 years, 150 years.
No, less, 1856, 150 years, yes.
And they refused to move.
And at that time the pyramid
was already discussed
and some people would say,
okay, if you must have it.
Mitterrand must want it.
Okay.
But I said, look here.
There's no point to build
the pyramid if we don't
have the Ministry of Finance.
So that gave the president
another headache.
But a long story short.
We moved them out in 1989.
So the second phase is the
building of the Richelieu Wing.
It's architecturally not
at all spectacular but very
important because why?
Because I had to
keep the facade.
Only thing I could do is inside.
And we demolished
everything inside
except a big suite
of Second Empire
rooms, very beautiful rooms--
you must go and see it--
and two or three staircases.
And the rest of Richelieu
was completely gutted.
So it was a major
engineering project,
but not very
spectacular except there
are some interesting
things inside, which
you will see when you come.
So because of time, I'm going
to start with phase one quickly.
MITCHELL: Do you have
your slide changer?
PEI: Oh, yes.
I'm going to have to
learn how to use this.
MITCHELL: That's the top there.
PEI: No.
Oh, yeah.
MITCHELL: And this one
for the other side.
PEI: Excuse me.
MITCHELL: We have to sort
out the technology here.
PEI: Oh.
Oh, I see.
MITCHELL: There we go.
Right.
PEI: Oh, I see.
Now I understand.
Okay.
Now Louvre as you
know it, perhaps
without too much debate among
architects and planners,
is perhaps the most important
urban composition in the world
today.
There's no other that
can compare with it.
Its history, 800
years, in the building.
It started as a
fortress and then was
added on by kings after kings.
But the important
kings to remember
that built the roof are
probably, I would say,
Charles V, Francis I, Henry
II, Henry IV, Louis XIII,
Louis XIV, and eventually
Napoleon I and Napoleon III.
And there are many other kings
in between that added something
to it, but those were
the important kings.
And it can also be
said that perhaps
every important French
architect, nearly every,
from Lescot to Mansart
to Le Vau and Louis
XIV, many, many others.
And then eventually
[INAUDIBLE], they all
participated in
the building of it.
So therefore it's not
surprising that you
come into this
wonderful complex, which
was already formed, and to
try to do something with it.
Now the reasons why something
had to be done to the Louvre
is for the reason
that you know, that it
was built first as a fortress.
And it was added on
and added on to try
to make it more comfortable
for king after king.
And to turn it into a museum
in 1793 at a convention
is a move that was
correct, interestingly,
because Louvre became a public
museum for the first time 200
years ago.
But it was not at all
suitable for a museum
because it was meant for
life, for kings to live in.
So Louvre has never
really worked as a museum.
I was there for the first
time on a fellowship,
not MIT but Harvard fellowship.
I did receive MIT fellowship,
but it was during the war.
I couldn't do
anything with it so.
I lived across the
street from the Louvre
in a tiny little hotel, and
I went over there every day
to look at it.
And I tell you, in
those years you really
have to have time to see
the Louvre because you
get lost in it.
And you don't know
where anything was.
There are no toilets,
no restaurants,
nothing of that sort.
But it had a
wonderful collection,
and you have to go back time and
time again to find surprises.
And that was the way Louvre was
to all of you, to many others,
until something
happened in 1989.
So therefore Louvre was a
wonderful complex of buildings.
But Louvre Museum was not.
Louvre Museum happened to
be a tenant in the Louvre.
That's all.
It was occupied by the
Ministry of Culture
running the Museum of France.
It was occupied by the
Ministry of Finance.
Occupied by many others.
Louvre Museum occupied a long,
long wing along the Seine,
and it's about, I would
say, 800 meters long.
And that wing was
almost impossible to go
from one end to the other
without going up and down.
And so therefore most people
who went to the Louvre
as I did probably only
saw maybe 25% of it.
The rest you just miss.
You have to have a guide.
And I didn't have a
guide, so therefore I
had to go back time and time
again to find new things,
new surprises.
So Louvre did not work as a
museum, and the French knew it.
But they wanted finally,
under Mitterrand,
to do something about it.
And the one move that was
perhaps the most important move
of all, I mentioned
earlier, it was
the recapturing of
the Richelieu Wing
from the Ministry of Finance.
Now this is perhaps
not a very good slide.
I apologize.
But you can see the
importance of Louvre
in the heart of Paris.
Because it's situated perhaps
in the most important, really,
the center, the heart of Paris.
And yet it's separated, the
left bank from the right bank.
There's no way to
penetrate except by car
from the left bank, which
is below, to the right bank.
So it became,
actually, a barrier.
And that became an urban design
problem of first magnitude.
Because we have to
open up the Louvre.
To open up the Louvre, then you
rejoin the two parts of Paris.
Not by car, you can always
drive around, but on foot.
And this is one of the
challenges that is least
talked about, but perhaps, in
my opinion, the most important.
The axis of the Louvre leads
all the way to Saint Germain.
And it all probably
is, again, when
I say the most important
urban composition,
I really should say that
it's the most important axis
of the world.
There's no axis like
that, that leads
all the way from the
Louvre to Saint Germain.
It went through the garden of
the Louvre, which you all know,
Place de la Concorde,
up Champs-Elysees
to the Arc de Triomphe,
and then on to La Defense,
and then La Defense beyond.
Now the Louvre.
This is a diagram of
the Louvre to show you.
The grey area on top was
occupied by the Ministry
of Finance.
The ocher, the yellowish
color wing, 800 meters long,
half a mile long occupied
not just by the museum,
by the museum and by the museum
administration of France.
And French bureaucracy, I tell
you, takes up a lot of space.
So it's not all busy.
You can see that people come by
the one side of the courtyard
and enter there
while you're waiting
in line if you're lucky, a
good day, you don't mind.
But then you'll be
pestered by people
trying to sell you all kinds
of things that you don't want.
But nonetheless, there are
people, 3 million people,
continue to come.
Why?
For its collection.
But you really have
to go through really
a very uncomfortable
experience in the process.
Now what I saw at
that time when I
was asked by the French
government to say,
can you do something
about the museum?
I said, I don't know.
But anyway, I'll try.
And the one thing that
became apparent to me
when I looked at this problem,
I said, the Ministry of Finance
has to go.
And I said, the
reason is simple.
I said, when you want to
build a modern museum,
what Louvre is-- why it
is not a modern museum
for a simple reason, and
that is, in modern museums,
which I knew well then because
I finished the National
Gallery already, so about
50% of exhibit space
has to be matched by 50%
of supporting spaces.
Reserve, conservation
laboratories, restaurants,
auditorium, lecture hall,
public's reception spaces,
toilets, things like that,
which it didn't have.
Tiny little toilets.
In fact, I remember very
well when I went there,
I frequently had to leave
the Louvre because I
had to find a place to go.
And then when you
leave the Louvre,
some people don't come
back again, you know.
So they lost a lot of people.
And it's not really surprising
that the average stay
of visitors to the Louvre
is only one hour and 1/2.
Whereas the National
Gallery is 3 and 1/2 hours.
Metropolitan Museum,
about the same.
So I said that the
key to making Louvre
function as a museum is to
change the Louvre from 800
meters long, up and
down, up and down,
to something very compact.
But you can give up this
wing, the floor where
the Spanish paintings
were, or still are,
and give it to other uses,
but you must move the Louvre
to that part.
In that way you
accomplish two things,
which is essential to making
Louvre Museum function.
Number one, you can
excavate that court,
which is in grey area,
the Napoleon Court.
We can go down two levels,
to the level of the Seine,
which is about 10 meters down.
You can go down
two levels, and you
recapture half a million
square feet of space
just by excavating that.
And why not?
You can use that
space for reserve.
You can use that space
for all the infrastructure
support that a
modern museum needs.
Because under the old Louvre
there's no foundation.
There's no space.
There are some pipes
and that's about all.
But nothing there.
There are some sewers
that go through.
But that is the key
to making the Louvre
into the modern museum.
Second reason is that if you
put the center of the Louvre not
on one side, down below,
but really in the middle
of the grey area, you've got the
center of gravity of the Louvre
right there.
And from that point you
can go to the three wings.
Louvre has three wings,
Denon-- Venus de Milo is there
and Mona Lisa is there-- and
to the Richelieu and to Sully.
Very short distance.
Not 800 meters anymore.
It's going to be only about
something like 50 meters.
The difference, so that
you can divide Louvre
into really three parts,
even though they're
interconnected upstairs.
Three parts, and each part is
at least several days' visit.
So a big museum, you
may wonder whether you
need a museum this size.
But be that as it may,
it's a big museum,
and that's the only way
to solve the problem.
So therefore I
told the president,
I said, you've got
to do two things.
You've got to let us
dig under the court
because there may
be relics there.
The project could
have been stopped
if they'd found something
important there.
And then you also
have to find a way
to move the Ministry of Finance.
At this point-- it's not
so funny at that time
because-- but this
tells you something
about the man who is still
the president of France.
I don't know of
any heads of state
in the world that has the kind
of breadth of understanding
of the history and
culture not only of France
but of the world.
He's really a remarkable man.
He may not be the greatest
politician, I don't know.
Time will tell.
But he was and he is a really
exceptional leader when
it comes to art and culture.
And I could not have done
anything there without him.
That's obvious.
The court, before we
did anything with it,
was a parking lot.
It's a parking lot for
the bureaucrats that
occupy the Ministry of Finance.
The court, after excavation,
finding-- one year
archaeologists were digging,
with really literally
with brushes.
And they found
things, all right,
but nothing terribly important.
Because this court,
unlike the court
which I wish I had slides to
show you, with a marvelous
dungeon foundation, is
now on display, which
when you go there you see it.
This court was inhabited by
people who served the kings.
Their bakers, their cobblers,
there's a little church,
and that's about all.
And therefore there's
nothing that is so important
that they say, stop.
We were very fortunate.
From '84 to '85,
that year we were all
waiting to see what happened.
We wished they
discovered nothing.
And the archaeologists,
of course,
wished they found something.
But anyway, they found
nothing of importance,
and we proceeded to
get the green light.
Now here I want to show you
the organization of the Louvre.
This is the court.
The rest of the Louvre
is not shown here.
It's only the Napoleon Court.
By putting an object, something,
in the center of this court,
let's say, in the
Napoleon Court,
you can connect the
three pavilions in a very
short and direct way.
And very understandable.
You can see it.
When you're in the court
or in the hall below,
you can look out and you can
see Denon, Richelieu, and Sully.
And that clarity of orientation
is key to a big museum.
This is an urban studies.
To try to ventilate
Paris, you must first
ventilate the Louvre.
To ventilate the Louvre you
have to do several things.
You can come over from the left
bank over Pont des Arts, which
is a pedestrian bridge,
wonderful bridge
architecturally.
From an engineering point
of view, a wonderful bridge.
And then you enter into cour
carree and then turn left.
But you have to do two things
in order to make it truly open.
One is that you have to open
that passage under Richelieu,
called Passage
Richelieu, to lead you
to the Place du Palais-Royal,
which is right there.
And then from then
on to Palais-Royal,
and then to Pompidou
Centre, which you know.
Second thing that you must also
do is to open up the garden.
A new bridge is
being built. I think
it's about to start
construction here,
so that you can walk
from Orsay, which
is where the wonderful
impressionist collection is
today.
From Orsay all the
way to the Louvre.
And that will open
up the Louvre.
And once that Louvre is opened
up, it no longer is a barrier.
It becomes a connector.
This was a drawing
done by Steve,
who's here, Steve [? Ohs ?].
I showed this drawing
to the president,
and he was not shocked.
Perhaps he was the only
man that was not shocked.
But when I showed it to the
press, they were shocked.
And I tell you, from
that point on, as I said,
18 months of just nothing
but harassment by the media.
But still, we got
the green light.
And the president as
well as his official,
who was in charge of the Louvre,
an important man, Biasini,
said, let's dig.
Because the archaeologist
has already said it's okay.
Let's dig.
And this was what you see.
And that was the beginning
of another furor.
And people demonstrating
and everything,
except trying to--
they didn't do
anything really serious like
committing suicide or anything
like that.
But very close, very close.
There were a few.
[LAUGHTER]
Now I'm going to go quickly
because of time, quickly.
To show you how the
building processed.
And the building of this
part is remarkably fast.
French contractors
are incredibly good.
I have to-- they're
very, very good.
These are slides that shows the
construction, the whole-- this
is the Napoleon
Court, by the way.
This is not the rest.
Only one part, the
important part.
This is the part where
the pyramid must emerge.
And the square grid that you
see, the structural steel
member there, they're
all on bearings.
It can move.
They move.
And they're supported on
four columns, and that's all.
We had about 60 or some sides
because from one vantage point
they took pictures
every so many months.
But I'm only showing a few.
So that's very quick.
But it took about--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
It took 18 months
to reach this stage.
And at this point I would say
it's the end of phase one.
It was opened in spring 1989.
And Mitterrand was
there to cut the ribbon.
And it was rather
well received by then.
But still, I would say there
were maybe 30% or 40% people
still not very happy with it.
And for any number of reasons.
But nevertheless, it was
built. And since this is MIT,
I thought I have to
bring this diagram.
If I show it to
another audience,
they would not be
interested in it.
And I'm going to show
you some of the slides
of the construction.
But one thing that
should also interest you,
that the French government
made no secret of it.
They want everything
to be made in France.
And the only exception,
which I asked the president
to allow us, is to have all
the tension elements made
in Massachusetts by a
small rigging company that
did the America's Cup yachts.
I don't know whether
Bill Koch is here or not,
but he would know.
And we are the best.
And I showed him some
samples of the rigging,
how the turn buckle was fit
into the cable and all that.
And he was fascinated with it.
Because he liked it so much that
he didn't even bother to say,
is there a French
equivalent to it?
We just say, go ahead.
So we did it.
On the other hand, as a
passing-- the glass problem.
You see, glass has to be
white, has to be clear.
If the glass is not
clear, this is laminated,
you know, it's double layer.
It's very thick.
It's about almost
3/4 of an inch thick.
If it's not clear
it would be green.
And if you see it through
the corner of this glass,
it will be very dark
green, bottle green.
So therefore that is not
acceptable because the Louvre,
you see, the composition
of the Louvre must be seen.
And the ocher-colored
stone shouldn't look green.
So therefore I requested
the French manufacturer
Saint-Gobain to make this glass.
They say, no, we no
longer make them.
And then finally they say, well,
if you built 1,000 pyramids,
we'll make them for you.
So I didn't report
this to the president.
I went to a German
firm, SCHOTT Glass.
I say, can you make it?
Yes, we can.
Saint-Gobain said,
we'll make it.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to go very quickly.
Making of the pyramid.
The pyramid has one virtue.
It's a very stable
form, you know that.
And consequently, it requires
the least amount of steel
in order to support it.
And consequently, if you
use the finest technology
available to you,
technologically, to build it,
it will be the most
transparent of form.
And it must be the
most transparent form
because you want to
see that composition.
That composition is so
important to the world,
not just to France.
So you may ask, do you need
something that projects?
Many architects in
France as well as abroad
suggested, why not just have
a glass sheet on the ground?
And you bring light
in just as well.
But I said, no.
I said, you have to have space.
You go into the lower level
10 meters down, 9 meters down.
And you don't want to
have a glass ceiling.
That word may mean
something to some.
Don't want a glass ceiling.
You want space.
And so something has to project.
And I defended the pyramid.
And the pyramid, for those
of you who know France,
is a very important
symbol to French.
I think the French are probably
more conscious of pyramid
as a form than any other people
because from Napoleon, I guess.
They really went to Egypt.
They took a lot of
things away from Egypt.
So the pyramid form is
necessary to give you
space, so when you--
give you light,
give you space, but at
the same time transparent.
You can see through it.
And also you need it simple.
Because if this is going
to be the main entrance
to the Louvre, it cannot
be just a subway entrance.
It just simply cannot be.
Glass was put in this manner.
And for a long time
there was a debate,
can you clean the glass?
And we tried different ways.
They hired some Indians
from Canada to clean it.
They even tried robot.
Eventually we cleaned by robot.
But finally we
got some alpinists
to get up there, hang the rope
from the tip of the pyramid,
and wash it.
And it only took
two days to wash it.
But now it took less.
Now one day is all we need.
So the washing problem
no longer a problem.
But for a while that
became also a problem.
Because the French
wanted to find
any reason to object to it.
And cleaning the pyramid
also kept us quite involved.
Now you're inside the space.
And you can see the Louvre.
You can see the
Louvre through it.
Ah, that was D-Day.
But no booing, no booing.
Lots of applause.
No booing.
That was-- ah, I
like that photograph.
You don't see anything.
There's a story about this
statue during Louis XIV's time.
Ah, I'm short of time.
I will try to go quickly.
Louis XIV's time.
They invited-- this
shows that in those years
the kings of France are
already very cultured people.
He invited Benini
from Rome to come.
Benini had just finished the
Saint Peter's arcade, the wing
that enclosed that space.
Perhaps [? Dandonne ?],
he and Borromini
were the two most important
architects of that time.
And the French king
wanted the best,
so he invited Bernini
to come to do something
in the back of the
Louvre, not this part,
in the back of the Louvre.
And he was there six
months, and he did not
survive the French architects.
And the only thing he
left behind-- there
are a few things he left
behind, not of importance--
but the only big thing
that he left behind
is the statue of Louis XIV.
But that was made in Rome,
and it was shipped to France
afterwards.
And Louis XIV never liked
it because it was his image,
at that time, was 25 years ago.
He was a young man then.
He's no longer young.
So he banished it to Versailles
and it remained there.
And because it was not known,
it was never vandalized
and never broke-- never,
I mean, never vandalized.
It was never destroyed
during the war
because it was just left there.
So, but it was marble.
It was vandalized by a man
from Brittany, anarchists,
I guess, and no
longer salvageable.
But I persuaded the
conservator of Versailles
to let us make a cast
of it, the only way.
And they did.
And it's made in lead.
And I thought he should put
it there to remember him
as someone who tried.
But very important,
that location.
I needed something
there to terminate
the access of Champs-Elysees
because Champs-Elysees--
that axis of La [? Note ?],
the La [? Note ?] axis
was not terminated
at the Louvre.
Because the Louvre is a little
bit like this, like this.
So it has to be terminated
not by the pyramid,
by something else
and something strong.
And I was fearful of
commissioning a French sculptor
at that time.
You don't know what's
going to happen.
I'm perfectly frank about it.
You just don't know what
to-- so that was my escape
from a responsibility.
Now second phase of the Louvre.
Not spectacular, not
at all polemical,
but extremely important.
Because now it opened
only a few months ago.
If you go there
now, you understand
why the pyramid was put
there in the first place.
And I think the vindication
of the whole plan
is now made possible through
the completion of this wing.
And for that reason, even
though architecturally
it's not spectacular because
the facade had to be kept
and everything has to be
internalized, done inside.
Number two, I had to work with
two French architects, which
is reasonable because,
after all, you know,
can't hog it all.
Now you see the end
of the Napoleon Court,
and this is what it looks like.
This is 10 meters below ground.
You go up three
sets of escalators
to an intermediate level,
still below ground,
and you can enter into the
three wings of the Louvre.
And the fourth
wing going this way
goes to shops,
parking, bus terminal.
Eventually, all the buses
that you see on Rue de Rivoli
as well as on the Quay will
disappear, as they have now.
They're all underground now.
So urbanistically, that's
another very important
contribution.
And below at this low
level, we have auditorium,
we have restaurants, we
have a reception area
for the young
people, and we have
a bookstore, enormous bookstore,
and shops, and meeting rooms,
and conference center.
Everything is there.
But below this level
is all circulation.
There's a truck way to
connect all the departments
underground.
And there's a large reserve so
that all the collection, nearly
all the collection, of the
Louvre now comes back home.
Now we have to talk briefly
about Richelieu Wing,
even though architecturally, as
I say, is not very spectacular.
The two courts were proposed
way back to be covered.
They were parking and trucking
for the Ministry of Finance
before, so not used.
By covering it, we can
turn it into an exhibition
space for French sculpture.
And further, we also proposed
to dig down below the Richelieu
Wing, as you see, so
that the two courts are
connected at the lower level.
And this was a
trucking area, which
now become exhibition
area for French sculpture.
This wing housed four
departments, the sculpture
department, the Oriental
antiquities department,
the objet d'art,
which is probably
the most important objet
d'art collection in the world,
and paintings.
I put this in mostly,
again, because this is MIT.
This is a pyramid about
50 feet square inverted.
Why inverted?
Because its position
at the place
where the circular rotary is.
And you don't want
to see any projection
there coming up because one
pyramid is quite enough.
But we used the same theme, and
we wanted to bring light in.
This is the intersection.
If you go to the bus
terminal, to the parking,
and to the shops, you have
to go through this point.
So therefore it's
nice to have something
to make people feel they're
still in the Louvre.
So now this suspended pyramid
is a major engineering project.
It was designed by
a man, Peter Rice
of Arup Associates in London.
And too bad I don't
have the drawings.
It's actually a very
brilliant design.
The whole thing
is-- there are only
four rods in the
center all suspended,
and the rest are all cables.
It's cables and four
rods, and that's all.
And it has one other
very exciting byproduct.
Clearly I was very proud of it.
Another very important
byproduct of this
is the prismatic
effect of the glass.
You see the glass.
Because we don't have to keep
water or rain out of this
because it's inside, we can
polish the edges of the glass
and bevel it.
By beveling it, a spectrum
of colors came out.
So at times you see on
a sunny day like this,
it's just a rainbow inside.
It's really quite spectacular.
If you go there, make sure you
go there on a good, sunny day.
Now the Richelieu Wing.
One thing has to be done
to the Richelieu Wing
because it's about the
painting collection.
It's perhaps the most important
French painting collection
in the world.
Not perhaps, definitely.
And yet people don't go there
because the French conservators
want it upstairs
because of daylight.
They are very, very
insistent on using daylight.
Our conservators are less so.
Very insistent.
And for that reason they
take the attic space.
They have a ceiling
not very high.
But to get up there, you have to
walk up 75 feet vertical space.
And most people
don't walk up there.
So they miss a lot of visitors.
I was told only about maybe at
the most 10% or 15% of people
go up to the top floor,
and that's a great pity.
So I proposed to
put in escalators.
I hate to do that.
It's a 19th century
building, and you
don't install
something like that
unless you have a good reason.
That was a big battle,
but it was won.
And today nobody disagrees
that it is absolutely needed
because otherwise the
interconnection up
and vertically, it's
very, very difficult.
Object d'art.
I showed you the
sculpture already.
I'll show you the objet d'art.
These are the
Maximilian Tapestries. .
Never shown before.
No place to show it.
Now they have a place.
And it's a must, the Maximilian
Tapestries are a must to see.
They're very dimly lit because
of the color of the threads.
Now before I go
into this, this work
here was done by architect
Villemard of France,
of Paris, France.
And my role in the
sculpture garden and this
is what they call,
really, a mandaterre,
so like a coordinator.
I participated in all
the decision making.
I chose them as my architects.
I had that responsibility.
But they should get
the credit for it.
Now this was old Louvre.
The lighting of paintings is
really a very special science,
it really is.
And it's extremely important.
It's never studied enough.
It just hasn't been.
We don't have good daylight
galleries in America.
We don't have it in
the National Gallery.
We don't have it in Museum
of Fine Arts in Boston.
They are all like this.
They are lay lights
with skylight on top.
And even though it could
have been artificially
lit and you wouldn't
know the difference.
And another disadvantage is that
the skylight is very bright.
And therefore the
brightness is the ceiling.
The second brightest
is the floor.
The walls, where you want
the light to be, looks dark.
And consequently,
we decided this
is something we want to
do a piece of research on.
And I think one of the
major breakthroughs,
I consider, in this
wing is in the lighting.
The lighting solution is this.
We make the ceiling
into three layers.
The first layer is glass,
skylight, with a UV filter,
of course.
And then below the
glass is an egg crate.
An egg crate is
carefully calculated so
that the orientation is such.
So no direct sun
rays will come in.
It would have been better
if they were movable
because then we get good light
all year around, all seasons.
Unfortunately, the
French have experience
with maintenance crew.
They say, it won't work here.
And they're right, they're
right, they're right.
So we use fixed louvers that
don't have to be touched.
We cut off a lot of light, a lot
more light than we wanted to.
But it does remove the headaches
of the gardien doing their job.
And the reason of
the big cross is
that people have to
walk there, so it
has to be wide enough for
people to walk, to clean,
to re-lamp, and
that sort of thing.
But you can see the sky if
you are walking on one side.
But the light, as you see now,
is deflected to the walls.
It's no longer coming
down to the floor.
So the walls now are
bright, and they get light.
And that has turned
out to be something
that the French conservators
are very conservative,
and they accepted this.
And they now claim this
is the best in the world.
They have this-- something has
to always-- and this they like.
And this is the
very important suite
of paintings by Rubens
celebrating Marie de' Medici's
journey and eventually
to apotheosis.
All the way, and
you can see again,
the light is no longer
bright on the ceiling.
It's directed to the walls.
And this is another
version of it.
Depending-- this is
an octagonal room.
That's a long room.
And the previous one I
think is a square room.
And this is the way
the light looks.
No reflection.
I guarantee you
that, no reflection.
All right.
Richelieu Wing was finished in
November, opened in November 9,
1993, exactly 200 years after
the founding of the Louvre.
And the Richelieu Wing, together
with the Napoleon Court,
is now complete.
And therefore Louvre
finally functions as the way
we had planned to.
And some of these
slides are mostly
to show you what it looks
like when it's all finished.
And young lady is
celebrating the event.
So there you are.
I think that's-- oh!
I used up too much time.
Well, sorry.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm sorry.
Ellen, I apologize.
Sorry.
I think we better go, huh?
We'd better go.
We're running out of time.
Oh, oh.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm not a professional,
as you see.
Like Professor Morrison.
Absolutely on time.
HARRIS: Thank you.
Thank you.
Well, you will see that we
are slowly moving through MIT.
We've had the
theoretical construct
for the relationship
between art and science
from the School of Science.
Now we've had our
presentation from the School
of Architecture.
And we are moving on to
the School of Engineering.
There's probably no better
representative from the School
of Engineering and representing
mens et manus, mind and hand,
than Richard Polich,
class of 1965,
who is president of the Tallix
Foundry for Arts Casting.
At the Tallix
Foundry, sculptures,
monumental sculptures, by many
of the best known artists have
been casted, are being casted.
Works by de Kooning, Stella,
Nancy Graves, Joel Shapiro,
and many, many others.
I think to describe
what Dick does there,
I've been privileged
to be to Tallix twice.
And I'd really like
to take all of you
to Tallix to see
the foundry, but we
will have Dick come and
show us pictures of it.
Maybe next time we
should go to the Louvre
and go to the foundry and--
[APPLAUSE]
But there was a profile about
Dick in the current Technology
Review, which I hope that
you were able to see.
And I want to quote
one passage from that.
It says, "Dick is multilingual.
He speaks structural engineer,
sculptor, and welder fluently."
Please help me to
welcome Dick Polich.
[APPLAUSE]
POLICH: Well, good morning.
We all need a little second
to let all that settle down.
That was just a wonderful talk.
And what I'm going to talk
about is a little bit different.
I'm an engineer, a metallurgist.
30 years ago I worked on a
project with Merton Flemings,
head of the materials science
department, the goal of which
modestly stated was to
unite technology and art.
We did indeed have a
resident sculptor, Al Duca,
who still lives here in Boston.
We all worked together
to adapt and modify
industrial techniques
to the making of art.
24 years ago I started
Tallix, a place
to make art, whose very name
comes from the material we
deal with, metallics.
In that 24 years,
Tallix has grown
to be the largest caster
fabricator in the world,
with over 100 people working
in 85,000 square feet
making art for artists
all over the world.
In fact, in the past
year we've installed art
in Luxembourg; Munster, Germany;
Rome; Vancouver; and Tokyo.
My hope today is to
accomplish three things.
First, to give you a tour
of the foundry and show you
what we do.
Secondly, to talk about a
specific problem for artists,
going from a small maquette
to a monument, the problem
of dealing with scale.
And then finally, end
up with a discussion
of how artists, engineers,
and fabricators work together.
So let's begin.
The artist who wants
to make metal sculpture
needs to find at least
four things, space, tools,
technology, and craft.
The artist will always
make art, but where
he makes that art,
the place he picks,
will affect how the art
looks and how it is made.
Let's look at the first slide.
Is there a pointer here?
CREW: Yes, right on there.
Underneath the equipment.
POLICH: This is it.
Okay, space we have plenty of.
We have about
85,000 square feet.
We have 46-foot ceilings.
The next slide.
Let me see now.
Not sure where that is.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
The next slide shows
the main bay of Tallix.
We have some Frank
Stella stuff over here.
There's a Lichtenstein
over there.
That's Audrey Flack.
That's a stainless steel
sculpture by Jeff Koons.
The scale of the place.
It's about 65 feet across
here and about 300 feet down
to the other end of the foundry.
The cranes have about 35
foot clear under the hook
and can lift up
to 100,000 pounds.
Tools also we have plenty of.
The next slide.
Here you see us out in the
yard assembling a sculpture
by Alex Lieberman.
It's a Cor-Ten steel sculpture.
Its dimensions are
50 by 50 by 40 feet.
It's an extraordinary
sculpture in that you
can walk inside this
sculpture, and it's
very unusual in that way.
The next slide.
We show some technology.
This is a sculpture that's in
the National Gallery, a quite
famous sculpture.
And its surface is terrible.
And this is one of
the things that we
have worked on at Tallix to help
sculptors achieve their goals.
The next slide.
These are the grain sizes of
three different cast bronze
alloys.
And while I was at MIT, I
did work on bearing steels.
And it turns out
that the same kinds
of things that make
better bearing steels also
make better surfaces
for sculptors.
And so on the next
slide, you see
some of the stuff
we have done where
the cosmetic appearance of
the surface, the perfection,
is so vital to what the artist
is trying to get across.
In the next slide you see craft.
I mean, this kind of story is
really the story of Tallix.
We have analyzed and
identified those interactions
between artists and craftsmen,
where they are really
working together to make art.
We have also got processes,
steps in the process,
that really are very little
different than making an engine
block.
And so we have tried to
separate those processes,
mechanize them, use
the latest techniques,
and try to keep this marriage
of technology and craft
going along.
In the next slide
you see a triptych
by Helen Frankenthaler.
And these really
are lithographs set
in a cast, a
stainless steel frame.
These are about 7 feet high.
One of the problems
in this sculpture
was what to do with
the back sides.
And we tried putting
fabric and putting
wood and various
other kinds of things.
And then-- the next
slide, please--
we went to using patinas.
And patinas are very
painterly kinds of things.
And you use brushes
and solutions.
The solutions are chemical, but
the techniques are the same.
In the next slide you see Helen
working on the bronze backs
that went onto the triptychs.
And this process is very
much like using watercolors.
The colors are transparent.
They blend into each other.
And there's ample opportunity
for accidents, happy accidents,
to occur.
In the next slide you
see one of the triptychs.
And this now is the
back side, and you
can see the incredible
designs and colors
that she has done for
the back of the screens.
In the next slide
is another one.
And then in the next slide
again another design.
And colors.
And I must say that at the
exhibit where these were shown,
only one of the triptychs had
the lithographs facing out,
and then the lithographs
were all facing the wall
as they showed all the backs.
And so there were some happy
foundrymen at that show.
In the next slide, this again
is a little bit of technology
and a lot of craft.
One of the things
that is going on here
is that we are brush plating
gold onto the bronze.
What happens then is
that the patinas will not
take on the gold, and
so the artist gets
this kind of extraordinary
transition from here, a green,
into the rich goldy color.
I think the next slide
shows a-- oh, no.
This is another case
of craft coming through
to help the artist.
The woman there is Mary Frank,
who does clay sculpture.
One of the things that
really troubled Mary was
that she wanted to do
marble, and, of course, fired
clay is very fragile and the
possibilities for putting it
outdoors are limited.
She wanted to do
metal sculpture,
but the surfaces were
hard and just reflective
and really bothered her.
And so we worked
out this approach
where we got a kind
of matte surface
with a patina that came
close to the original clays.
In the next slide I'm going
to now talk about some
of the problems with scale.
These are 35-foot figures
in Rosslyn outside
of Washington, DC.
It's what you see as you
come up to this building.
The thing that goes on
when an artist is faced
with making a
large-scale monument,
and, as Professor
Morrison talked about,
the hands and the
eye working together.
Artists invariably work at a
size somewhere between a foot
and 3 feet, something like that.
I think the hands and
the eyes coordinate well,
and that's the size.
Now you've got to make
something, though,
that can be outdoors, something
that can go in the world.
And the world is a big place.
Well, typically, if I took
a piece of paper, crushed it
in my hand, and threw
it on the table,
you would sense the force
that had crushed it.
You would see the folds, the
lines, the kind of energy
that's in that piece of
paper, in that crumpled paper.
I now take it, and
an artist says, well,
make it 10 feet by 10 feet.
What happens is that somehow now
all of those folds and creases
and lines have moved apart.
And there's a lot of information
that has to be put back in
to make that work.
And what is possible
to have happen
is that this large model, it
becomes an imitation thing
and it really doesn't work.
In this case-- the
next slide, please-- we
were taking as a starting
point a painting,
and we're working with kind of
big geometric simple shapes.
The next slide.
We have here again in
the bay of the foundry,
and we are making
this structure.
We've got the problem
of hurricane winds.
You'll see that it's quite
delicately poised on its toes,
so we have to put a lot
of structure inside this.
The next slide, please.
Here we are in the main
bay of the foundry.
The figure is standing
together for the first time.
You can see all of
these are really
weld points where the surface
skin is welded to the structure
inside.
And there indeed is a copy
of the original painting.
And that is the artist
admiring her work.
The next slide.
This is what you see as
you leave the building.
And I think this is just
a very successful project.
It's a wonderful kind of
thing to see coming and going.
In the next slide we have a
sculpture by Roy Lichtenstein.
And this is a brush stroke.
The next slide shows
this sculpture at,
I think it's 22
feet in the foundry.
And then the next slide shows it
going into a building in Paris,
of all places.
But again, you can see that
they're big, simple forms.
The colors are well defined.
And this sculpture goes up to
a larger scale quite readily.
The next slide.
This is a
two-dimensional painting
by an artist named
Richard Pousette-Dart.
And I was really
quite amazed to see
in one of Mr.
Pei's slides, which
showed a topographic
map of Paris,
how this related to that.
It seems close to me.
One of the things-- I don't
know if that was Mr. Dart's, Mr.
Pousette-Dart's inspiration.
But one of the
things that we had
to do now in consultation
with the artist
was to figure out what's
up and what's down.
How do we make this
three dimensional?
And so we made it
into a clay model.
Next slide, please.
And you can see now, this
is the modeling clay.
It's gone from a painting about,
I think it was 5 feet by 6 feet
to a 12 by 12 door.
This door was for the museum at
the Indianapolis Museum of Art.
And in the next slide
you see the door
set in a limestone wall.
The next slide shows the
inside of the building,
and the door is
pivoted in the middle,
and so it rotates
on a central hinge.
And I think we have one more
slide, which shows again
the door set in the building.
Again, I think a very
successful enlargement.
Next slide.
This is a sculpture
by Tom Otterness,
which went to Germany.
Here is the maquette.
This is about 3 feet high, and
we're enlarging it to 8 meters.
The construction
here is quite simple,
stainless steel tubes with
bronze elements inside them.
The next slide, please.
Here you see it in the
main bay of the foundry
at its full height.
I think that is the model there.
And again, here
is the sculpture.
Again, this sculpture
lent itself readily
to being enlarged.
Next slide.
Here we are in Washington,
and what's going on here
is that this is the
installation of the Joel Shapiro
sculpture at the Holocaust
Museum in Washington.
This sculpture was 23 feet high.
The next slide shows the
sculpture in the foundry.
Shapiro uses wooden forms.
The sculptures are
almost minimum.
They're these simple wooden
forms that go together.
This is a figure that is a
double figure that represents
a kind of resurrection theme.
You see here the actual size
of the elements that we cast.
There was a real
problem here in that,
when the sculpture
got this big and we
used wooden beams
to cast off of,
the wood grain did not carry.
And Shapiro finally went back
to the sawmill and dinged one
of the teeth of the saw and
then ran it through the sawmill
and left a pattern
that was strong enough
to come through at this scale.
The next slide shows Joel--
that's Joel the artist there
now-- adjusting
locating the sculpture.
And this is just
interesting that it
shows the kind of involvement
that goes on between artist
and fabricator engineer.
Next slide.
This is a sculpture
by Gifford Proctor.
And this sculpture is
about 30 inches high.
And it's Washington at
Valley Forge, very dramatic.
It was on its way to 20 feet.
In the next slide you
see the enlarging machine
at the foundry.
This is a pointing device.
The original sits on this table.
The thing you're making
in clay works over here.
There are two styli.
The center line of the tables
and the center line of this arm
is on the same point.
There's a pivot back there.
And so this makes
one similar triangle
that's similar to this.
So if this distance is
one and this is five,
you can get a five
times magnification.
This technology goes
back to the Renaissance.
So it's being displaced by
lasers and devices like that.
But computers
[CLEARING THROAT] excuse me.
Computer-driven cutting
machines at this scale,
it's just very difficult. The
equipment is so expensive.
Next slide.
Here we have the body.
These are Washington's elbows.
And what happens
now is we really
start to get into
trouble because we've
got this enormous expanse
of fabric or cloth
or whatever it is, and
it's a real problem
as to what to do to keep
the sculpture interesting,
to keep your eye moving.
This sculpture was really
never cast at that scale.
Let's go on to the
next slide, please.
Here we have an artist,
Willem de Kooning.
And de Kooning did
this sculpture,
which is 9 inches
high, and then it
was enlarged four times to
3 feet and then four times
to 12 feet.
In the next slide,
the kind of technique
that de Kooning was
using was really
working these
things in his hand,
squeezing clay in his hand.
And you can see
in the next slide,
you can see this kind of very
tactile thing that's going on.
In the next slide again,
you see it even better.
Now these sculptures, when
they were first enlarged,
the first enlargements
were really
scrapped because the
information from there
to there was not there,
and the artist had
to come back and work very
closely with the enlarger
to get something that
kept your eye moving, that
kept your interest.
The next slide, please.
This is Frank Stella.
And Frank Stella
is certainly one
of the top artists of our time.
And Stella's here
working on a clay.
And he looks like he's
working with a rake.
Well, he is working with a rake.
And Stella is a really
cerebral, available guy
who will discuss with you and
tell you what his problems are.
And he's got a clay here.
The total clay is
about 12 feet across,
and he's trying to make
a mark on it that's
appropriate to this scale.
And Stella feels that the
hands are too small, too weak.
The gestures they
make are too timid.
I mean, what he's looking for
is something that will show
force and movement and energy.
And so I've actually
seen him go in there
and jump on the
clay with both feet.
I mean, it's a real problem.
And in the next slide
you see how Stella
is starting to approach it.
This is part of a sculpture,
which you'll see in a minute.
It's about 25 feet
high, this one element.
And in it we have an
enormous number of new forms,
of new surfaces, of
things that Frank
is trying to do to
keep you interested,
to have a surface that's dynamic
and changing and interesting.
In the next slide,
here's another sculpture,
and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about this.
But this dumpster is actually
part of the sculpture.
[LAUGHTER]
I agree.
But I'm going to talk
about that, about where
an artist gets his images.
And one of the
things that Tallix is
is a resource image
bank for artists.
And almost everything
we use in the foundry,
Frank has put in one
sculpture or another.
The next slide.
This is another sculpture.
And these are also
painterly things.
I mean, Stella started
out as a painter.
And a painter can take
a 12-inch-wide brush
and go in and cut out
big parts of his painting
by overpainting.
And Stella is looking for
that same kind of energy
and possibility for change.
The next slide, please.
This is that sculpture.
One reviewer described
the sculpture
as looking like
an airplane crash.
And that's funny in a
way, but it's also true.
I mean, Frank is
looking for gestures.
And you take a big steel
tank, and you crush it,
and so you put the history
of that event in there.
And we respond to
it, and sense it.
In the next slide, again,
some of these things that
are going on.
And then closer, in the next
slide, closer to my heart,
here we are trying to
make one of these forms.
And Stella is so
experimental and so open
that I'm going to talk some
more about him in a minute.
But here we are.
He has assembled
this pile of junk.
And sometimes there's
no other word for it.
It really is a lot of junk.
But we are pouring 5,000 pounds
of aluminum on this sculpture,
on this stuff, to make
a new kind of form.
I mean, this is a kind
of casting without molds.
And what happens is, we
get directional patterns.
The things get knit together.
And we have here really
a new mode of expression.
And again, going back to
Professor Morrison's talk
about the real world,
this is very real world,
but it's also dreamland.
So I think that's
the last slide?
No, I have some other slides.
And again, going back to
Professor Morrison's talk.
And we did not discuss
each other's talk.
But here, one of the
things that really binds me
as an engineer to the casting
process is the process itself.
And in early times people who
worked with metals were shaman,
they were magicians.
I mean, after all, the first
metals, meteors from heaven
and Mother Earth
disgorging gold nuggets.
So metals have always had a
very powerful role in our lives.
And these are ceramic
shells that we're
going to fill with metal.
And we preheat them because
they're so impermeable.
And we have to keep the metal
molten long enough to fill out.
The next slide shows
us pigging off-- not
pigging off-- tapping off into
a crucible of molten steel.
And then the next slide is
the actual casting process,
which is violent and
wonderful and dangerous.
Next slide.
Again, more of that.
And then the last slide is
the molds have been poured,
and they're set aside to cool.
And the next slide is
just entropy taking over
and everything getting back
to the same temperature.
OK, I think that's
it for the slides.
I want now to talk a little bit.
After now we've seen
how the foundry looks.
I want to talk
about how it works.
But first it should
be understood
that the art being discussed
is limited to the plastic arts
and sculpture in particular.
We'll begin by making a clear
distinction between creating,
fabricating, and engineering.
Creating, while
difficult to understand,
is fairly easy to describe.
It's what the artist
does when he works,
when he expresses himself.
What it is not is something
made as a means to an end,
something made to a
preconceived plan,
or something made by imposing
a new form on a given material.
In other words, art is made
deliberately and responsibly
by people who know
what they're doing,
even though they
don't know in advance
what is going to come of it.
To create a work
of art, the artist
must have in him certain
unexpressed feelings
and the wherewithal
to express them.
Making a sculpture,
then, has two stages.
Making the plan,
which is creating,
and then imposing that
plan on certain materials,
which is fabricating.
Thus, when the engineer makes
a plan, he, like the artist,
is creating.
It is not art, however, because
it has a preconceived goal.
Remember, in art you don't
have a preconceived problem
to solve.
You're trying to
express something.
Sometimes the engineer, as
in my case, wears two hats.
He makes the plan, but then he
also serves as the fabricator.
Let's look at fabricating.
The fabricator needs an
idea of what is to be made.
Typically, the artist presents
an artifact in a plastic medium
and wants it transformed
into metal, perhaps
at a larger scale.
In the simplest case, the
engineer's not needed at all.
The deal is really between
artist and fabricator.
In this case, the artist
has a very specific problem,
which can be solved by the
application of an existing
technology.
So when does the artist
need the engineer?
Well, under at least
five instances.
No artist, and
probably no engineer,
can be familiar with all the
material processes available
and the number of materials
an artist can use.
In my own case, I listen
to the artist's intention
and then describe a
number of different ways,
different processes, to
achieve the artist's goal.
This conversation
often occurs very early
in the process of
creating a work of art.
Then there is the near
obsession to be novel,
to do something
never done before.
Casting and fabricating are
really fairly straightforward.
New technologies
appear and are used,
but for the most part
solutions of this type
combine unusual or offbeat
ways of doing things.
For example, casting aluminum or
bronze around stainless steel,
stopping the anodizing
process at a point
where the artist can paint
colors rather than dipping,
using plating
techniques selectively,
welding metals together with
different color welding rods.
These suggestions sound simple,
but they can be of great use
to an artist in achieving
a unique effect.
Then there's the
exchange of information
between artist and engineer.
The artist wants to know
why something happened,
what things can't or
won't work, and perhaps,
most importantly, which
things might work.
It is sometimes
difficult for an artist
to explain what
he's trying to do,
for it may not be
completely clear to himself.
The engineer fabricator
must be a good listener,
able to pay attention, and
intuit what the artist wants.
Providing a source of imagery.
Tallix is visually
a fantastic place.
Artists come to Tallix to see
all the different work being
made, feel the
energy of the place,
and are enormously
stimulated and motivated
to create new works.
And finally, make it
all cost effective.
In the end, everyone has
to deal with the costs.
Let's return to the
fabricator who wants and needs
an image of what is to be made.
The artist as creator
sometimes does not
have a strong sense
of how important it
is for the fabricator to have
that final idea available.
Minus it, confusion
and muttering result
as artist and fabricator
slip past each other
pursuing their common
but different goals.
Fabricating is important to the
artist but in a different way
than for the fabricator.
Fabricating gives the
artist the opportunity
to identify elements he may
want to use in his composition.
The fabricator works from a
model, a drawing, a sketch,
some kind of guide, while
the artist has none of these
and only gets exact
when he's completed,
when the sculpture is finished.
Another sticking point in the
push-pull between fabricating
and creating is that the
fabricator cannot provide
the artist with
elements of imagery.
Only the artist can decide
what images he wants.
He may recognize
and use some images
from the work of the
fabricator, but only
after he has understood
what has been made can
it have a place in his work.
To summarize, the
artist is expressing
an emotion, a feeling he is
not conscious of until it
is expressed.
The engineer participates
in the process
by making a plan to accomplish
the artist's vision.
The fabricator follows a
plan with a clear objective,
an artifact as the goal.
I want now to talk about
how different artists work.
Most artists come to the
foundry looking for advice
and consultation on how to
achieve a specific result.
These artists have mostly
resolved their work
in the studio and
have well-formed ideas
of what they want.
Often they will have discussed
with the foundry particular
aspects of a project long
before it is completed.
In fact, the
discussions often affect
how the sculptures
are fabricated,
as technical advice becomes
a compositional element which
the artist may use or discard.
Some typical foundry responses
for artists are as follows.
Roy Lichtenstein,
the pop artist,
wanted his sculpture to
have an industrial finish
like a galvanized trashcan
to keep the pop image even
while using the very permanent
and expensive process
of casting.
Nancy Graves loves color.
Nancy comes to
sculpture as a painter.
And so we did enameling
of the cast bronzes.
And she also liked
direct casting.
And so we figured out ways to
cast lobster claws and flowers
and other flora and
fauna with her signature
touch of fragility and
[? metastability. ?]
For Richard
Prousette-Dart, we've
already seen how we took
that two-dimensional painting
and turned it into a 12
foot by 12 foot door.
These are some of the things
we've done for various artists.
But the artist I'm
going to focus on
is the afore-- [AUDIO OUT] with
his assistant, Earl Childress,
chooses to work directly
and at scale at the foundry.
This is a bold, expensive,
complicated work.
But what it does is give
Frank the possibility
to assert artistic influence
at every possible stage
of fabrication and
therefore clarifies how
one artist can and does work.
For Stella, a major goal is to
include as much information as
possible in his work to
make it as rich and full
of character as possible.
He wants the complexity
of history and chance,
and he is not bothered by
the source of the richness.
For example, human beings
always bring the promise
of enriching work, not
only by their actions
but by accident as well.
Frank will ask for
something to be done.
Bend that piece of metal, cut
that piece into four elements.
The logical question is, okay,
what angle is the bend to be?
Do you want it symmetrical?
Are the cut pieces
to be equal sizes?
These questions
Frank never answers.
He says, bend it, cut it.
He's looking for richness.
Frank is open to everyone's
ideas and suggestions, looking
for that idea he could
never think of himself.
Perhaps the cutting or
bending of the material
will be done in some
new and interesting way.
If it doesn't work, if it
isn't interesting, he dumps it.
He will not compromise.
Working for some artists
is like making a product.
This group of artists is trying
to achieve a specific result.
But Frank Stella is composing
images, building the sculpture,
feeling it go together.
When Frank is at work, making
images, accepting some,
rejecting others,
there's a real sense
of fitting the specific
elements to each other,
making them feel right
as well as look right.
Historicity of elements
is what Stella wants,
not in the traditional
way but in a new way.
The old way was go to the
studio and do trial and error
experiments.
Now there are too many
possibilities, too
many complexities.
The artist needs help to
understand the possibilities,
so he goes to a
fabricator like Tallix.
Even so, Stella is very unusual.
In his quest for richness,
he is eager to use
any possible imagery the
process of fabricating offers.
This is not what
most artists seek.
Frank thinks that the
process of testing
does not give people ideas.
People get ideas by thinking.
Frank says, if the artist has
a novel idea, he feels good.
If he has an original
idea, he is happy.
People value expression.
They don't have enough of it.
Art gives back
something, a notion
of the nature of the
material, of casting,
and man using tools to
shape and form materials.
A sense of all the forces,
a lot of them at work.
To make something
is to act like God.
To make, you must use
force and your mind.
One of the big
differences for Stella
between art and engineering is
the value of an original idea.
An idea in art is
only good once.
Thereafter, it is repetition.
But a good engineering
solution can
be used many times over
and over until a better
solution presents itself.
Sometimes engineers
feel artists are
capricious and
self-indulgent when
really what they
are responding to
is this fact that they
must avoid repetition.
What are some of the ways
Stella works that can
be applied to engineering?
For starters, take his openness
to ideas other than his own
and his own quest for richness.
Stella doesn't care
where ideas come from.
He wants work rich in ideas.
To some, this might sound
like plagiarism, but it isn't.
There's a difference
between using
what exists as a
springboard for your work
than as the basis for your work.
In my personal experience
over the past 10 years,
I can report that
everything we use
at the foundry-- tools,
cutting tables, work benches,
dumpsters, drops; that's what's
left after a form has been
cut out of a metal
sheet-- all of it
included in Frank's imagery.
Of course, the ultimate drop
is another artist's scrap
sculpture, which, of
course, no one can use,
but it is tempting.
For what could be a better
foil, a better alternative view,
than another artist's sculpture?
Next is Frank's effort
to stay uncommitted,
to keep as many possibilities
open as possible,
no matter how many
problems this causes
the fabricator with his
need for a final vision,
a goal to be achieved.
Remember, the
fabricator's skills
are his knowledge of the means
necessary to achieve a given
end.
There the artist is,
substituting images, testing,
trying to see what works
best, sometimes unsure
until it is done while
the fabricator writhes.
How can one work for
someone, he thinks,
who doesn't seem to
know what he's doing?
While in fact the artist is
doing exactly what he must
do to complete the project.
In conclusion, I want
to do two things.
The first is to review
what the artist as typified
by Frank Stella does, and then
to draw some conclusions as
to what might be
applicable to the education
of the young engineer.
First, what I see
Frank doing, what I
will call the artist's way.
Get as much history and richness
as possible into the art,
including the processing
and the evidence
of man working with tools.
Do not commit too soon.
Stay as open as possible
as long as possible
to other solutions,
for it is in the making
that one sees
fulfillment of his ideas.
Be aware of changes and the
effect those changes have.
A brief tale.
We were making a lot
of stainless steel
castings for Stella in 304.
A project for another artist
came in that required 316.
As an engineer, I'm
accustomed to looking
at these materials finished.
And finished, it's almost
impossible to tell them apart,
and the differences in
composition are not great.
So to give someone
316 is like being
moved into first-class
seats if the tourist
section has been overbooked.
We made castings
in 316 for a while
and then switched back to 304.
Almost immediately
a cry went up.
What's going on?
It turns out that 316
in the as-cast condition
looks very different
from 304, something
we engineers had been totally
unaware of, but not the artist.
Finally, invest self.
If the artist's idea
fails, the artist fails.
If you want to get
more out of something,
give more of yourself.
That's the way of the artist.
All of them make sense to me and
deserve serious consideration
by young engineers.
But there's more.
Bright young people
come to MIT to learn,
to learn the latest and the
newest technology, what works
and how it works.
In the study of science
and engineering,
a discarded or
disproved idea is just
that, discarded,
interesting, perhaps, only
in where it was wrong.
In engineering, there's
also a real-world test.
Questions totally
inappropriate to works of art
get asked of the engineer,
like, what's it for?
Did it work?
Did the bridge fall down?
Contrast that to art, where
discarded ideas and artists can
and do reappear.
And certainly in art,
there is no sure test
for the quality of art.
What can happen, then, to the
young engineering student which
has not happened
to the artist is
that he may overvalue the
contribution of his teachers
and either ignore or not develop
awareness of his feelings
and the importance of
expressing those feelings.
We need to, and I hope are doing
so, as evidenced by all of us
here today, make young engineers
aware of the importance
of including their own
feelings, their own expression
in the solutions
to problems they
will face in their careers.
We can make that more possible
by providing opportunities
and making sure that
these opportunities are
important to our
community for our students
to express themselves.
Or failing that, provide them
with frequent opportunities
for aesthetic experiences.
Whether or not this will make
better engineers can and will
be debated.
But art and aesthetic
experience will
do what it always has done.
Enrich the individual and give
a historical and aesthetic
perspective, an
artistic dimension,
to our students'
understanding and aspirations.
And given the ever-growing
power of engineering,
perhaps it's not
too wild to suggest
that this new engineering
will give creators like Stella
compositional liberties
unimaginable not so long ago.
Perhaps one can even
imagine students
being taught, as I
have learned working
as an engineer for artists,
function can follow form.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HARRIS: As we
continue our journey
through the schools at
MIT, we have arrived
at the School of Humanities.
And my five years
at MIT are nicely
bounded by the MIT performance
of Professor Tod Machover's
opera "Valleys" in June
of 1989 and the premiere
of John Harbison's cello
concerto at the Boston Symphony
Orchestra in just April 1994.
And speaking of the
Boston Symphony Orchestra,
let me take this opportunity
to offer them a special thanks
today to the orchestra,
to the players,
and to the Boston Musicians
Association of the American
Federation of Musicians Local
9535 for their permission
to tape the final rehearsal
of John Harbison's concerto
and to play portions
of that this morning.
Both Tod and John represent
the broad spectrum
that exists not just
across the arts at MIT
but even within single arts.
While Tod works
with and develops
new interactive
technologies that
have included a new
series of hyperinstruments
and a wired conductor's glove
that interacts electronically
with the players instruments,
John works with pen and paper
and conducts the
traditional way,
as recently when he
conducted Handel's "Messiah"
for the Handel
and Haydn Society.
But both composers have
written viola concertos
for the same artist,
Kim Kashkashian,
and both have written cello
concertos for Yo-Yo Ma.
Both explore and create
sounds and structures
that have never before existed.
And both are steeped in the
continuum of historical music
making.
Helping to tie this
discussion together today
is Lloyd Schwartz,
professor of English
at University of
Massachusetts Boston
and classical musical editor
of the Boston Phoenix.
He's a regular commentator for
classical music on National
Public Radio's Fresh Air.
Just this April Mr. Schwartz
was awarded a Pulitzer Prize
in music criticism.
John previously has
won a Pulitzer Prize
for his oratorio.
And this spring, I have to say,
won the Killian Faculty Award
at MIT, the highest award
given to faculty members
at the Institute, an
award that was previously
won by Professor Morrison.
And I am delighted that John is
the first professor in the arts
to have won that award.
And it gives me great
pleasure to introduce
Professors Machover,
Harbison, and Mr. Schwartz.
[APPLAUSE]
MACHOVER: Which
side to you want?
SCHWARTZ: I'll just [INAUDIBLE].
Good morning.
MACHOVER: Just, I guess.
SCHWARTZ: This is-- part of
this is the entertainment
part of the program
today because you'll
get to hear some
brief selections
of some wonderful music.
Certainly one of the
joys of being a music
critic in this city
has been to experience
the new works of
these two marvelous
composers, who also happen to
both be on the faculty at MIT.
We'll hear two clips
of recent pieces.
John's brand-new cello concerto
performed by the Boston
Symphony Orchestra, and
Tod's cello solo piece,
which is solo and for cello and
computer, "Begin Again Again, "
which had its premiere
at Tanglewood in 1991.
And I'll ask each of them to
introduce the brief clips.
HARBISON: In the
talk show format,
I'm supposed to be very
surprised there's a clip.
But actually I-- I
know that there is one.
What you're going
to see and hear
is three minutes, no
more, I assure you,
by our contract with
the Boston Symphony,
of-- actually less-- of a
segment from the first section
of my cello concerto, a
rehearsal tape, which we were
allowed to take with available
sound and available light
and one camera angle.
That being the
case, and this being
a much more visual
than oral world
that we live in, as
has been pointed out
by various of the
previous speakers,
there's attached to it right
at the beginning 50 seconds
of somewhat more lively visual
material from a documentary
from Wisconsin Public Radio.
Which I guess sort
of quickly flashes
by you, various parts of my
life to the accompaniment
of another concerto, "Concerto
for Brass and Orchestra,"
on the Los Angeles
Philharmonic recording.
So you'll hear all
together four minutes
a little sampler of this
and that and then a bit
of the Boston
Symphony rehearsal.
Guess that's it.
SCHWARTZ: Can we have that clip?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - JOHN HARBISON,
"CONCERTO FOR DOUBLE BRASS
CHOIR AND ORCHESTRA"]
-I think the artists can't
be only on their own side.
They have to look
for a voice that
says what's not being said.
We have to be terribly
connected to the strongest
things in the tradition in order
to be able to make something
that's new.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - JOHN HARBISON]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
MACHOVER: Beautiful.
SCHWARTZ: Tod.
MACHOVER: Now we'll see a
clip of about equal length
of the piece that I wrote for
Yo-Yo Ma about three years ago
called "Begin Again Again."
Yo-Yo is, well, he's
almost alone on stage.
You'll notice that
there's only one musician,
but there are a series of
computer technicians on stage.
And Yo-Yo is playing something
like a cello, but not exactly.
One of my interests
in general has
been to make technology
be in the service
of human expression, to
make it easier for people
to communicate and
express themselves
because of technology.
And we designed here
at the MIT Media Lab
a special cello for
Yo-Yo for this project.
The general category is
called hyperinstruments,
and this is therefore
a hypercello.
The cello itself is
somewhat different.
It's made out of
wood, but it needs
to be amplified to be heard.
And you'll notice Yo-Yo has
cables coming out of his bow.
He has a funny
thing on his wrist.
And there are other little
antennas poking out.
The idea of all of this work
is to amplify and expand
what can be done with a normal
instrument by using technology
and to allow the musician
to be as natural as possible
in using this new
instrument to use
all the skill and musicianship
that a performer like Yo-Yo
has.
That musicianship
is then interpreted
by the instrument itself, and
different layers are added.
So what you hear
is a solo piece.
But through Yo-Yo's
playing, the notes
he plays, the way
he phrases them,
the color he gives
to his instrument,
the computer responds and adds
to the various different layers
that you'll see.
At the end of the clip you'll
notice that he goes back
to his normal instrument.
In this piece, part
of the idea was
that there's kind of a
struggle between the artist
and the technology,
which becomes reconciled.
We monitor his instrument at
the end just with a microphone.
So this is a little bit
from "Begin Again Again."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And last month they premiered
their piece "Begin Again Again"
at Tanglewood.
[MUSIC - TOD MACHOVER, "BEGIN
AGAIN AGAIN"]
-The whole goal of
my artistic work
is to make connections
between things
which seem to clash
when you first
look at them without
making the effort.
And in some ways
about how hard it is.
[MUSIC - TOD MACHOVER, "BEGIN
AGAIN AGAIN"]
-And listening to
any piece of music
is like going into
a different country.
You go there, you're
stimulated because it sounds
like a different language.
But yet some things
are the same.
So you figure out what the
values are in that new place.
And essentially you
go on an adventure.
And this piece is not
so far out that it's
incomprehensible to anybody.
Anybody that likes music,
that responds to it, I think,
is going to be able to
find something in it
to hold onto as a
point of departure.
And then the adventure
begins for them.
[MUSIC - TOD MACHOVER, "BEGIN
AGAIN AGAIN"]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SCHWARTZ: Yo-Yo Ma is
another Boston-area resident.
And I think until just
a few years ago he
was really far better
known for his performances
of traditional classical
music written for the cello.
I think that
reputation is changing.
One of the things that
I've been eager to ask
you is, what was working with
or for Yo-Yo Ma really like?
And maybe the more serious
side of that question
is, how much of the work of
composition in these pieces
was inspired by the fact that
you knew you were writing it
for a performer like Yo-Yo?
John?
HARBISON: Well, we were
joking before we came on
that, just once in these talk
shows, someone should say,
he's a terrible
fellow and he was
uncooperative and difficult.
Because usually they say,
it's just-- life on
the set was great
and we all loved each other.
Well, in truth with Yo-Yo
he is a wonderful colleague.
He's very genuine and direct
and tremendously committed
to what he does.
And it is a very
wonderful experience
to write for a performer
who's eager for what
he's going to get.
I'm sure Tod had
that experience too.
I mean, where is the piece?
Let's have it.
Let's talk about it, is
definitely the attitude
that he takes.
And by the time I wrote my
piece for him, he had played,
I think, five or
six, maybe more,
cello concerto premieres
and was clearly very
gripped by the idea of
spiriting pieces into the world,
as you say, rather
different from the earlier
part of his career, where
this was a very rare event.
So just his excitement at
that part of his musical life
is, I think, very
infectious to a composer.
SCHWARTZ: How much of what's on
the page, what's in the score
do you hear as Yo-Yo
Ma, if anything?
HARBISON: In this case,
I'm sure in Tod's case,
that Yo-Yo was the whole thing.
It was extremely direct.
In my case, this concerto
is much more centered
around the soloist than other
concerti that I've written.
Probably only my violin
concerto is equally so.
I've been more
interested in fitting
the orchestra together with
the soloist in other pieces.
Here I really wanted the
soloist to be the central focus.
And I think it was
partly because I
knew that, no matter
what happened,
he would hold the
stage, both on virtue
of his presence and
the way he plays.
So I really thought I
should just go with that.
And I, in fact,
even in the themes
thought I was dealing with
him somewhat biographically.
But he didn't particularly
like that idea,
so I dropped it rather
quickly in terms of talking.
But I think there is
some element of that.
SCHWARTZ: Do you think his sound
is in the contours of the music
that you've written for
the cello in that piece?
HARBISON: It probably is.
I think at the
same time you also
hope that other
cellists will play it
so that I think you
go not so totally
into the particularities
of the player
that you rule out
other approaches.
But I think very much, yes.
And his sound has also had some
influence on other cellists
by now.
SCHWARTZ: You were writing
something for Yo-Yo
that was completely new to
him because he was actually
playing an instrument,
the hypercello, which
he hadn't played before.
What was your
experience with that?
MACHOVER: Well, many things.
One of the reasons that Yo-Yo
was interested in the project
was because he was very
concerned about thinking
about the future of
string instruments
and thinking about
how they could evolve.
He was actually quite interested
in knowing about new things
about computer programming.
Just hanging around
the Media Lab,
for instance, and finding out
what the students were doing.
And at that time he was
interested in CD-ROMs
and where that would go.
I agree totally
with John that one
of the things that struck
me about this project
with Yo-Yo is, here we
were starting from scratch,
designing a totally
new instrument
with new ways of playing it,
took longer than we expected.
But from the very
beginning of the project,
Yo-Yo would always come and
say, so what's the piece about?
What am I meant to convey?
The instrument's fine,
that'll be great.
We'll make it, but what will
it leave the audience with?
And actually got me to
talk about that earlier
in the process, while I was
still planning and writing it,
earlier than I usually talk
about that to other people.
Another thing about Yo-Yo.
A lot has been said today about
different styles of thinking
and engineering and
intuitive things.
Yo-Yo is one of the
very rare performers,
maybe-- I can't think of
too many other people-- who
is both incredibly
gifted physically, just
like a great athlete.
I think he probably
started playing the cello.
And I would guess he
probably didn't have
to practice incredibly hard.
I'm sure he did practice hard.
But he just has an
amazing natural gift.
He can pick up an instrument
and learn things very quickly.
It's just phenomenal.
At the same time, he's
truly an intellectual
and has always been very
interested in figuring out
why physical gestures bring
out certain results, how
music works.
And for a project
like this where
we're trying to take a lot of
things which musicians often
take for granted, how
do you express phrases
through the bowing,
how do changes in pitch
convey little different
bits of meaning?
It's not obvious when
you stop to think about
that how you can
break that down, let's
say, in an engineering way
so that you can teach that
to a computer.
And Yo-Yo is one
of the few people
I know who is such
a great performer
and also is both interested
and capable of thinking
through those problems.
One of the side
problems of that,
because of the fact
that he's so naturally
gifted, is that in the early
stages of the project when
our hypercello was pretty lousy,
actually, it didn't feel good,
didn't sound good, we
could give him anything
that we'd come up with.
The original things looked
like black pieces of plastic
and they sounded like
electric guitars.
And he'd come into the
studio and we'd say,
okay, Yo-Yo, is
this good enough?
What do you think about it?
And he'd sort of play it and
play some Bach suites on it
and say, oh, yeah, it's great.
Feels wonderful.
So in some ways he
wasn't so demanding
because he could play anything.
But he was very, very
easy to trade ideas with.
SCHWARTZ: So did
he actually affect
the composition of the piece
while you were working on it?
Or was that separate
in some way?
MACHOVER: I actually
don't think he
affected the actual composition.
But I think since we were
talking about it while I
was writing it, I think he did
make me aware of certain things
that I'd put in the piece.
For instance, when we had
the first rehearsal where
there was actually a bit of
a few themes here and there.
I'm a cellist
myself, and when he
started playing
through the piece,
he said, you know, this
reminds me-- maybe you
didn't think of
this-- but it reminds
me of the second solo suite
by Bach for cello in D minor.
And when he said that, I
realized that in many ways
he was true.
It wasn't just in the
kind of feel of it.
But in the tonality my piece
also centered around D.
In the sense the piece is
called "Begin Again Again,"
and it's a set of variations.
It's kind of about
the performer trying
to break out of a certain mold.
He keeps trying to have
the melodies go up,
and they keep turning
around and going down.
And there's a kind of circular
process like that in the Bach.
And when he put
his finger on that,
I don't know that it changed
the rest of the way I wrote it,
but it definitely clarified
what I was working on.
And I never in a million years
would have thought of that,
for instance.
SCHWARTZ: Have you performed
this piece now at this point?
MACHOVER: Yeah, not for
too many people, but.
Also, I must say, I've
written other cello pieces,
which I do perform.
One thing about this piece
is that, because he's
such a great virtuoso, I
didn't kind of restrain myself
in terms of how
difficult the piece was,
which was really a problem when
I decided to perform it myself.
It was quite a bit harder
than what I usually write.
And another thing is that,
since I knew it was for Yo-Yo,
somebody who tours a
lot and also learns
many different pieces, I really
wanted to write a piece where
this hyperinstrument would
really do something new
but also would feel
incredibly natural,
would not be so hard
for him to learn
how to make the transition
from normal cello playing
to this different
kind of instrument.
So it was a certain
way that I changed it
because it was for him.
SCHWARTZ: The reason
we're here, you're here,
is that you're both
on the faculty at MIT.
And John, how do
you see yourself
fitting into musical,
cultural, academic life at MIT?
HARBISON: Well, the simplest
answer is, of course,
that I don't fit in.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
There's more to it, though.
The idea of fitting in is,
in some situations, terrific.
And for someone like
Barry Vercoe or Tod,
the resources of MIT are
obviously phenomenal.
For me, the resource
of MIT was really
the difference, that is,
the sense of not fitting in
was, at least for
a lot of my life,
tremendously salutary for me.
I've always loved that feeling.
And even probably
begins back at the time
I told my parents I wanted to
compose an orchestra piece one
summer and they sent
me to baseball camp.
MACHOVER: Did you
write the piece anyway?
HARBISON: I did.
I did.
But I think some of us who
started out here in music
at MIT a long time ago in Klaus
[? Lipan's ?] days were aware
that though the core of us
were the kind of musicians
that Ellen described of sort
of Stone Age technology,
with not even mechanical
pencils, you know.
We were aware that
MIT would need
to develop in directions
appropriate to the resources
of MIT.
And that was part of what--
one of the first things I
did at MIT was participate
in the search for Barry
Vercoe, who came and started
the computer music at MIT.
And I think Tod's
first appearance here
was in the summer
course that Barry held
for a number of summers here.
We also saw fairly
early on that we
needed to go in the
direction of world music.
And we began, actually, in the
mid-'70s and that direction.
So I think some of us who are of
the dead white male persuasion,
of which I've been told I was
already part, have in some more
or less visionary way tried to
see how the resources of MIT
could connect to the arts
as well as preserving
a place for some of us who are
obviously involved in doing
essentially what I was thinking
of when I was five years old,
which is adding some pieces to
a repertoire, which at that age
I already thought
was extraordinary.
And I've stayed so
interested, really,
in string quartets
and orchestral music
that that's really where I
expect I'll probably wind up.
But MIT is incredibly
hospitable to all kinds
of activity in the arts.
And our students are
extraordinarily diverse.
Some of them really
just want to learn
how to play a Schubert
trio, and others really
want to find out on day one
how the computer can help them
as artists.
And I think that that
diversity is something
that we're trying to, with
the resources we have,
we're trying to respond to here.
SCHWARTZ: Do you have
any impulse or temptation
to take advantage of the
electronic facilities
here in your own music?
HARBISON: Well, in
1971, I think it was,
I rented the largest
Hammond organ I could find,
and I wrote a piece
called "Bermuda Triangle"
for amplified cello, Hammond
organ, and amplified saxophone.
And using those draw
bars, I felt like I
was in my own computer studio.
And I was very excited.
I really thought that was the
direction I was going to go.
But my one early experience
in the very early days
of the computer
studio, I think I
was environmentally somewhat
averse to the smallness
of the rooms and so forth.
I don't think
that's true anymore.
People work in
nicer environments.
But I may be at
this point so filled
with projects in what we call
the acoustic world, which
when I started out
was-- I was amazed
to be told I played an
acoustic piano a few years ago.
I always thought it was
a-- that I may be occupied
that way to such a degree
that I may never wind up.
I always have in
the back of my mind
I should really try this out.
And every once in a while when
I see Tod he says, come over
and we'll plug you in.
SCHWARTZ: I think your
role here is more expected
and understandable.
What do you do?
Tell us some of the
things that you do here.
You do more than
just compose music.
MACHOVER: Yeah,
well, most of you
probably know about the
Media Laboratory, which is
one of the newer parts of MIT.
It opened up in 1985.
And the Media Laboratory has
kind of as a central goal
to find ways of making
technology so that it responds
more to what human
beings want to do,
either in communication
or in expression.
And hopefully to find
ways of developing
new forms of what
might be expressed
when the technology
and the tools change.
So it's true.
I try to-- it's funny.
As John says, he has
projects for quite a while
now that, because of
what he's already written
and because of his interests,
are acoustic projects.
I think because I'm at MIT
and because I work so much
with technology,
most of the projects
that I see coming
my way are projects
that involve more technology.
I sometimes-- before I came
to MIT, I used to sort of work
for a couple of years
with new technology.
And then I always
wanted to take a break.
In fact, I have a
new CD coming out
soon with one piece
for piano and computer
and another very large piece
for piano all by itself.
And I don't do that
so much anymore,
and I sometimes miss it.
But one thing that we
do at the Media Lab
is we do big projects to
make different kinds of music
and art pieces that
involve technology.
We also spend a lot
of time thinking
about the technology,
the tools themselves,
that can be used by musicians.
For instance, I mean, for
John, I think in some ways
this technology is
terrific right now,
but it has so far to go.
It really isn't
quite at a stage yet
where John would probably
be satisfied with it,
quite honestly.
I mean, there's
just so much to do
to make technology be as
sophisticated as traditional
instruments, both
in the way they
sound and the way they feel.
One thing that-- I teach
at the Media Laboratory.
I give a two-term course.
The first course is
kind of everything
you've always wanted to know or
maybe not know about computers
and music and technology.
And the second term
is a project course,
which is kind of interesting.
One thing that I find at MIT
is that all the students I --
I really mean this-- the
students are the most
open-minded, intelligent,
and kind of nice people that
I've met anywhere.
They're really-- no,
they're fabulous.
They also have incredibly
different backgrounds.
And especially when you find
people coming to a music class,
nobody knows the same thing.
Many people have bits of
things they've specialized in.
But since they haven't
been to conservatory,
they've often played
an instrument,
and they've done a
lot of their science,
they're often--
sort of, I see them
almost as pieces of a puzzle.
When you put them
all together, you
have an enormous
amount of knowledge.
So I sort of go
out of my way when
I choose people for my
class to pick people who are
very different from each other.
I usually pick people who
are both graduate students
and undergraduates, people who
are engineers, and hardware
builders, and composers, and
performers, and sometimes
visual artists.
And in the second
semester we often end up
doing things which
I don't think really
could be done anywhere else.
My students just this last
weekend put on-- the idea
was to find a new
form of concert
where there were no performers
and the public who came in
were the performers.
And we took a big, open
space at the Media Laboratory
and designed something with a
whole set of new instruments
where people came in with
no instructions, no guides
to tell them what to do.
And by using their voices
and by using their gestures,
they became part of
this music piece.
And it was incredible because
it was all done by students.
All I really did
was teach them what
they needed to know to do
it and then kind of managed
the project.
But all the work was theirs.
And it really stacks up
to anything of that--
if you think of
interactive entertainment
and where Hollywood
is going, this
is an example of how that can
be done with kind of substance.
And I can't imagine that really
being done anywhere else.
SCHWARTZ: How rapidly is the
technology itself changing?
MACHOVER: It goes
in fits and starts.
The huge change in
music technology
happened about 10 years
ago, really literally
10 years ago, when three things
happened at the same time.
It was the big boom of
the personal computer,
so all of a sudden you
could get your own computer
without a lot of money.
The second thing is
Yamaha in particular
bought the patent for a way
of making computer music very
cheaply.
It was developed at Stanford.
They bought the patent.
And all of a sudden computer
synthesizers came out.
Then instead of only being in
places like MIT and Stanford,
you could buy for $1,000.
And the third thing,
which was remarkable,
is that all the people
making these computer
music instruments developed
a standard way of basically
a cable called MIDI
of hooking together
any computer and any
synthesizer to send computer
information back and forth.
So all of a sudden
computer music,
instead of becoming kind
of an abstruse thing,
became something
which is so common
that even if you don't know
it, probably all of you
listen to computer music all
the time in Hollywood film
scores and most advertising and
more and more classical music.
What we all found in
the last few years
is that that was also
very constraining.
And now there's a
whole new revolution
where basically,
especially because
of interactive
entertainment, you know,
what you see happening with
communication companies
and cable companies
and computer companies
and the whole
Hollywood industry, all
trying to figure out what it is
they're going to do together.
I've never seen a period
of such rapid change
as in the last six months or
so, not only in terms of people
investing in new
interactive entertainment,
but trying to figure
out what to do.
And it's one of the
first times I've
seen where we at the Academy
have had to be incredibly
fast on our feet to
think of new ideas
because there are very smart
people in the commercial world
who are thinking
of stuff every day.
And a lot of it's at least
as good as what we're doing.
So it's a very
stimulating time, I think.
It's changing very,
very fast right now.
SCHWARTZ: Do you have any
questions for each other?
HARBISON: Well, we can talk
to each other here at MIT.
SCHWARTZ: But not in public.
In that case, I
think we're hungry,
and we've had a rich morning.
Thank you very much.
MACHOVER: I guess you're right.
[APPLAUSE]
HARRIS: If I could have your
indulgence and attention just
for a moment, please, we will
get to lunch, I promise you.
I feel a little bit
like a camp counselor.
However, there are
a few announcements
that I would like to make about
this afternoon's programs.
Very briefly, I promise.
One is that-- now
remember, the workshops
for those of you who will be
here are from 3:00 to 5:00
this afternoon after lunch.
On this stage will be
the sing-along with John
Oliver, who will be conducting
"Jesu, meine Freude."
All of you who have
acoustic voices
are welcome to come
and give this a try.
This is something that the alums
have asked us to do for years.
We're going to do it this
year and hope that some of you
will come on stage.
In your program booklets it
says that, during this workshop,
a videotape of John
Harbison's Yo-Yo Ma concerto
will be played.
Of course, you
have just seen it,
and it will not be played
again this afternoon in Kresge.
I wanted you to know that.
I also must announce with
very deep and personal regret
the sad news of Professor Muriel
Cooper's unexpected passing
last week.
She was one of the
speakers who was expected
to speak at another
workshop this afternoon,
the one at the Media Laboratory
entitled Arts [? Bytes. ?]
However, members
of her laboratory
have stepped forward
enthusiastically and generously
so that the work from the
Visible Language Workshop
will still be presented at
the Media Lab this afternoon.
The other workshops
are a workshop
on theater, which we will be
able to participate and view
an ongoing rehearsal of "Who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf?"
Downstairs in Little
Theatre from 3:00 to 5:00,
a creative writing
workshop in Killian Hall,
where you will hear MIT faculty
read from their recent work,
including Alan Lightman
reading from his New York Times
bestseller Einstein's Dreams.
And Bill Mitchell
will have a chance
to talk this afternoon
at a workshop on design,
New Directions, which will
be held across the street.
Don't forget, for those
of you who are in town,
there will be tours tomorrow
morning at 9:30 and 10:30
at the MIT Museum and
the List Visual Arts
Center of current exhibitions.
There will be tours
of the new biology
building at 9:30
and 10:30, leaving
from the Wiesner Building.
There will be a
tour at 10 o'clock
of the outdoor sculpture
collection at MIT,
which has been named
the best in New England.
Tomorrow afternoon
from 2:00 to 4:00,
there will be the opening of
the Center of Advanced Visual
Studies' 25th anniversary
retrospective exhibition
at the MIT Museum.
And Sunday afternoon,
for those of you in town,
the spectacular opportunity
to hear a performance
of AR Gurney's love letters.
Gurney, who has been a member
of our faculty for many years,
with the parts read by Gurney
himself and Kitty Carlisle
Hart, who has been a member of
the Council for the Arts at MIT
since its founding in 1971.
I thank you all
for participating
in this View of the
Arts at MIT, and I
hope you enjoy the rest
of your reunion weekend.
[APPLAUSE]